其他人：就是做大明星相关的一些内容
Others: I do content related to big stars.
其他人：所以说今天来就是来看你
Others: So today I'm here to see you.
其他人：来看一下
Others: Just to check things out.
其他人：学习一下
Other People: Let's learn something.
其他人：就是加入人才
Other People: Just adding talent.
其他人：格外风景就很有意思
Other People: The extra scenery is very interesting.
其他人：然后我觉得这个实验好像也很有趣
Other People: And I think this experiment is also very interesting.
其他人：然后他也感觉他态度很好
Other People: And he also feels that his attitude is very good.
其他人：然后我们一起来看下怎么样
Other People: So let's check it out together.
其他人：然后到处都是摄像头
Other People: And there are cameras everywhere.
其他人：感觉
Other People: It feels...
其他人：好像有种在录那个出门的世界的感觉
Other People: Like we are filming the outside world.
其他人：有一种感觉
Other People: It feels...
其他人：我希望大家今天玩的开心热闹一些哦
Other People: I hope everyone has fun and gets lively today.
Tasha: 干嘛要呀
Tasha: Why is that necessary?
Tasha: 哦哦
Tasha: Oh, oh.
Shure: 10个币子
Shure: 10 coins.
Shure: 来小杜你
Shure: Come on, Xiao Du, you.
Shure: you deserve it
Shure: You deserve it.
Tasha: 什么玩意
Tasha: What the heck?
Tasha: 10个币啊
Tasha: 10 coins?
其他人：快快快哎
Other People: Quickly, quickly, hey.
Tasha: 干嘛呀我不是生人
Tasha: What? I'm not a stranger.
Shure: 好的下一波从8个币子开始
Shure: Okay, the next round starts with 8 coins.
Tasha: 我我不是嘉宾吧
Tasha: I'm not a guest, right?
Tasha: 从8个币开始
Tasha: Starting with 8 coins.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 完了市场要崩了哈哈
Shure: Oh no, the market is going to crash, haha.
Tasha: 我靠这不就一个币
Tasha: Oh my god, that's just 1 coin.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 3块钱就一斤
Tasha: 3 bucks for a pound.
Tasha: 24块钱到家了
Tasha: 24 bucks to your home.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
其他人： 不是这给三个
Other People: No, give three...
Tasha: 给8个币
Tasha: Give 8 coins.
其他人：大家好我是来自  大学的
Other People: Hello everyone, I'm from the Communication University of China.
Tasha: 给8个币不是变成虚拟币了吗
Tasha: Give 8 coins, didn't it become virtual currency?
其他人：我是可欣的室友我们啊
Other People: I'm Kexin's roommate, we...
Tasha: 会涨到他们账户里吗
Tasha: Will it go into their accounts?
Tasha: 会会对
Tasha: Yes, yes.
Tasha: 那不就行了
Tasha: Then it's fine.
其他人：我是来自   大学的
Other People: I'm Liu Yifan from the Communication University of China.
Tasha: 但是现在那个币的实体价格是0美金
Tasha: But now the physical price of the coin is 0 USD.
其他人：然后我就是I的
Other people: And then I'm an I type
其他人：特别明显的I人
Other people: Very obviously an I type
Tasha: 啊是啊
Tasha: Ah, yes
其他人：哈哈哈
Other people: Hahaha
其他人：就是在在我高中第一次进宿舍的时候
Other people: It was like when I first entered the dorm in high school
其他人：这个姐姐半个月对我说的第一句话是
Other people: The first thing this girl said to me after half a month was
其他人：我一直以为你是个特别高冷的人
Other people: I always thought you were a very cold person
其他人：不说话了
Other people: Didn't say anything
其他人：后来发现全部是这样
Other people: Later found out everyone is like that
Tasha: 我高冷吗
Tasha: Am I cold?
其他人：就是在陌生人面前会比较嗨
Other people: You get quite hype in front of strangers
其他人：高冷不了一点
Other people: Not cold at all
Tasha: 我吗
Tasha: Me?
其他人：在熟人面前立马变异的人
Other people: You change immediately in front of people you know well
Tasha: 你刚开始接我的时候
Tasha: When you first met me
Tasha: 觉得我高冷吗觉得你
Tasha: Did you think I was cold?
其他人：谢谢大家
Other people: Thanks everyone
其他人：我觉得你暴躁
Other people: I thought you were irritable
Shure: 然后刚刚说的是几个必字来着
Shure: So how many "must" words were just said?
Tasha: 啊暴躁
Tasha: Ah, irritable
Tasha: 暴躁老几
Tasha: Irritable old person
Tasha: 我吗我吗
Tasha: Me? Me?
Tasha: 好吧
Tasha: Okay then
其他人：没见面的时候
Other people: Before meeting
Tasha: 没见面的时候
Tasha: Before meeting
Tasha: 什么什么时候
Tasha: What, when?
Shure: 那我们下一个环节啊
Shure: Let's move on to the next segment
其他人：现在在微信群里发了个到
Other people: Now posted in the WeChat group
其他人：为什么还不来啊
Other people: Why haven't they come yet?
Shure: 不是呸
Shure: No, ugh
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 下下一下一个介绍
Shure: Moving to the next introduction
Tasha: 我在什么微信发了个到
Tasha: When did I post in WeChat?
Shure: 5个必字开始
Shure: Starting with 5 "must" words
Tasha: 为什么还不来
Tasha: Why haven't they come?
Shure: 5
Shure: Five
Tasha: 呵
Tasha: Hah
其他人：他就觉得你好凶
Other people: He thought you were fierce
Tasha: 真的吗啊
Tasha: Really?
Jake:2
Jake: Two
Shure: 4
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
其他人：假的
Others: Fake.
其他人：太廉价
Others: Too cheap.
Shure: 三
Shure: Three.
Tasha: 行我记住了
Tasha: Got it, I'll remember.
Shure: 3个了
Shure: 3 now.
Shure: 别别别炸了两个
Shure: No, no, no, two exploded.
Alice:上吧上吧
Alice: Go, go.
Shure: 2个
Shure: 2.
Shure: 一个了然后后面呢
Shure: One left, then what?
Shure: 就可就没有了
Shure: Then there’s nothing.
Shure: 我们后面的拍品非常的精彩的
Shure: Our next items are really amazing.
Shure: 我们提前看过大家的这些
Shure: We've checked them out in advance.
Shure: 这些派品都非非常的非常的棒
Shure: These items are really, really great.
Shure: 真的真的没有在自告奋勇来
Shure: Seriously, no one is volunteering?
Shure: 来介绍一下的吗
Shure: To introduce them?
其他人：需要一个支点
Others: We need a pivot.
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It’s okay.
Shure: 那6个
Shure: Then 6.
Shure: 6个不能再多了啊
Shure: 6, no more.
Shure: 只有6个
Shure: Only 6.
Shure: 再给大家最后3秒钟考虑时间
Shure: You guys have 3 more seconds to decide.
Shure: 没有
Shure: No?
Shure: 我们这波就直接进行下一环节了啊
Shure: Then we’ll move on to the next segment.
Shure: 3 21
Shure: 3, 2, 1.
Shure: 好的那我们结束introduction环节
Shure: Okay, we’re done with the introduction segment.
Jake:我们花了整整5分钟哈哈哈
Jake: We spent a whole 5 minutes, haha.
Shure: okay
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 那我们就进行呃
Shure: Let’s move on to the gas auction segment.
Shure: gas的那个拍卖环节吧
Shure: Everyone, take a look.
Shure: 然后大家看
Shure: At how many coins you have.
Shure: 一眼自己手头的币子都有多少
Shure: Right now, whose...
Shure: 现在谁的
Shure: Who has the least coins should go first.
Shure: 要不谁的币子少谁先上来拍
Shure: Haha.
Shure: 呵呵呵
Shure: Here you go.
Shure: 给你给你
Shure: Take it.
Shure: 先赚点钱吧
Shure: Earn some money first.
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Tasha: 拍他们的东西好像
Tasha: Bidding on their stuff seems...
其他人：其实是带了一点很好玩的东西来的
Other: Actually, I brought something really fun.
Tasha: 很好
Tasha: Great.
Tasha: 他的东西
Tasha: His stuff
Tasha: 我最期待
Tasha: I'm most looking forward to it.
其他人：这是一个钥匙扣
Other: It's a keychain.
其他人：但其实是里面是那个胶片黑白卷
Other: But actually, inside it's black and white film.
其他人：奇怪的图片
Other: Strange pictures.
其他人：是我自己去拍的
Other: I took them myself.
其他人：然后今天带了5个
Other: And I brought 5 today.
其他人：它是基本上都是风景
Other: Mostly they're landscapes.
其他人：应该是有四张大海
Other: There should be four of the sea.
其他人：然后有一张是个楼房
Other: And one of a building.
其他人：是的
Other: Yes.
其他人：就是很神奇的是因为它是黑白卷
Other: The amazing part is that it's black and white film.
其他人：所以正常这么看是看不到的
Other: So you can't see it normally.
其他人：需要用光对
Other: You need light for it.
其他人：这边需要去用光照一下
Other: You need to shine some light on it.
其他人：看到它的那个
Other: To see its
其他人：里面的形状还蛮有意思的
Other: shapes inside, which are quite interesting.
其他人：就是好看好看好看
Other: It's really beautiful.
Alice:老公给我买一个哈哈哈
Alice: Honey, buy me one, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：就是相当于是你如果把它挂起来的话
Other: So if you hang it up,
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha!
其他人：是有呃随身带的一小片
Other: it's like carrying a little piece of the sea with you.
其他人：属于自己的海的那种感觉
Other: Your own piece of the sea.
Tasha: 我们四个能买两个吗
Tasha: Can we buy two for the four of us?
其他人：而且你可以去
Other: And you can
其他人：就是通过对着手机的手电
Other: use your phone's flashlight
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know.
其他人：或者对着阳光才能看到他
Other: or sunlight to see it.
其他人：蛮有意思
Other: It's quite interesting.
其他人：我觉得蛮有意思的
Other: I think it's quite interesting.
Tasha: 就是什么
Tasha: So, what is it?
Tasha: 一个底片的挂件钥匙扣
Tasha: A film strip keychain.
其他人：然后邱老师定个价吧
Other: And Mr. Qiu should set a price.
Tasha: 我出你就别出你出我就别出哈哈哈
Tasha: If I bid, you don't. If you bid, I won't, haha.
Shure: 肖老师觉得这个每张呢就
Shure: Mr. Xiao thinks each one should be
Shure: 一个起拍
Shure: Starting price
Shure: OK那就先一个起拍
Shure: OK, let's start with the first photo.
Shure: 好吧总共有5个
Shure: Alright, there are a total of 5.
Shure: 那么第一张
Shure: So, the first one.
其他人：第一张是什么呀第一
Others: What's the first one? The first one?
其他人：要拿手电照进去吗
Others: Do we need to shine a flashlight inside?
其他人：哦对
Others: Oh, right.
其他人：这五张其实不是同一个地方
Others: These five photos are actually not from the same place.
Tasha: 张是什么
Tasha: What are the photos?
其他人：应该就是山东沿海的那几座城市
Others: They should be from those coastal cities in Shandong.
其他人：我是不是要把那四个给还给他
Others: Should I return those four to him?
Tasha: 我不是给你四个了吗
Tasha: Didn't I give you four?
其他人：都拍过然后大概是从呃
Others: They were taken around, um...
其他人：所以我得还给他是吧
Others: So, I should return them, right?
Tasha: 你还呀
Tasha: Yes, return them.
Tasha: 这是我们俩共同资产
Tasha: They're our joint assets.
其他人：20年到现在都是疫情时候拍的
Others: Taken during the pandemic from 2020 until now.
Shure: 这张是一个有着
Shure: This one is of a sea with many reefs.
Shure: 很多礁石的一个海
Shure: A sea with many reefs.
Tasha: 拍了
Tasha: Got it.
Shure: 然后起牌下一
Shure: Then, the next one.
Tasha: 哦还在
Tasha: Oh, still there.
Shure: 一个两个
Shure: One, two...
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two, once...
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, twice...
Shure: 好我这边出3个
Shure: Alright, I'm putting out three.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 3个一次
Shure: Three, once...
Shure: 三个两次啊
Shure: Three, twice...
Shure: 还有没有想要的
Shure: Anyone else interested?
Shure: 这个这个
Shure: This one, this one...
Shure: 非非常的beautiful
Shure: It's very beautiful.
Shure: 这个我跟你讲
Shure: Let me tell you...
Shure: 这是这五个里面比较不错的一个
Shure: This is one of the better ones among the five.
Tasha: 我天哪
Tasha: Oh my god.
Tasha: 他对他自己女朋友的太平大家赞赏
Tasha: 非常的停留了非常多的时间
Tasha: He spent a lot of time on it.
Shure: 三个三次
Shure: Three, thrice...
Shure: 那就自产自销一下了
Shure: So, it's self-produced and self-sold.
Shure: 好了
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 我我我收下了
Shure: I-I-I accept it.
其他人：怎么回啊
Others: How do we reply?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
其他人：怎么回啊
Others: How do we reply?
其他人：没有没有
Others: No, no.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
其他人：我在是因为昨天他跟我讲
Others: I was here because he told me yesterday.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
其他人：然后找了一下
Others: And then I looked for it.
其他人：噔噔噔噔噔噔
Others: Dun dun dun dun dun.
其他人：没有别的可以
Others: There was nothing else.
其他人：不像我说话了吧
Others: Doesn't sound like me, right?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 那我们下一个
Shure: So, the next one.
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
其他人：刚刚以为你要发我刚刚以为你要发
Others: Just now, I thought you were going to send it. Just now, I thought you were going to send it.
Shure: 哦这是一个栏杆旁边的一个大海对
Shure: Oh, this is a big sea next to a railing, right.
其他人：怎么回啊
Others: How do we reply?
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Tasha: 哈哈哈给
Tasha: Hahaha, here.
其他人：我笑死
Others: I'm dying of laughter.
Shure: 也是起拍价一
Shure: The starting bid is one.
Shure: 一一个 2个
Shure: One, one, two.
Shure: 两个一次
Shure: Two, once.
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, twice.
Tasha: 下次就可以出售
Tasha: Next time, it can be sold.
Shure: 3个 3个一次
Shure: Three, three, once.
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, twice.
Shure: 还有更高的吗
Shure: Any higher bids?
Shure: 三个三次落锤
Shure: Three, three times, sold.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold.
Shure: 哎呦完了
Shure: Oh no, it's over.
Tasha: 哈哈哈切
Tasha: Hahaha, cut.
Tasha: 我们是中产阶级
Tasha: We are middle class.
Shure: 还有
Shure: Also.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Shure: 还有一个啊
Shure: There's one more.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 第三个
Shure: The third one
Shure: 第三个是一个
Shure: The third one is a
Tasha: 初价两个
Tasha: Initial price for two
Tasha: 等会
Tasha: Hold on
Shure: 他有一个是楼
Shure: It has one building
Tasha: 不许让他们一个起拍
Tasha: Don't let them start with one
Shure: 其他的其实都是海哦
Shure: The others are actually all sea
Tasha: 直接让他们两个买断
Tasha: Just let them buy two directly
Shure: 这是这一张
Shure: This is this one
其他人：实在不行我就掏出我的本
Others: If it doesn't work, I'll pull out my notebook
Shure: 是青岛那个银泰帆船中心的船
Shure: It's the boat at Qingdao Yintai Sailing Center
其他人： 掏出我贪污的用
Others: Pull out the embezzled funds
Tasha: 等会他说说话
Tasha: Hold on, let him speak
Tasha: 你就直接说两个
Tasha: You just directly say two
Shure: 这是一个带有船的海
Shure: This is a sea with a boat
其他人：贪污的
Others: Embezzled funds
Shure: 还有后背景是一个摩楼
Shure: And the background has a skyscraper
Tasha: 哦好
Tasha: Oh, okay
Tasha: 不要到最后一个再拍
Tasha: Don't bid on the last one
Tasha: 最后一个一般会很高
Tasha: The last one is usually very high
Shure: 还有一些楼对
Shure: There are also some buildings, yes
Shure: 起拍价一个一个两个
Shure: Starting price is one, one, two
Tasha: 两个
Tasha: Two
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Shure: 两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two, once
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Shure: 两个两次哦
Shure: Two, two, twice
Shure: 他又三个
Shure: He has three again
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Tasha: 这就是资产阶级
Tasha: This is the bourgeoisie
Shure: 哎呦四个
Shure: Oh, four
Shure: 四个一次
Shure: Four, once
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: Four, twice
其他人： 快快快快快快啊
Others: Hurry, hurry, hurry!
Shure: 4个三色so成交
Shure: Four, three times, sold!
其他人：你要争起来
Others: You need to compete
其他人：你快点啊
Others: Hurry up!
Tasha: 你干嘛哈
Tasha: What are you doing, ha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
其他人：还是我刚刚下去现找了两个
Others: Or I just went down and found two
Alice:哈
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Shure: 然后大家拿到手可以其实用
其他人：我要增加一下我的拍卖资金
Lucia: 这个如果大家一会有人喜欢
Tasha: 这是我的吧
Lucia: 也可以拍拍试试
Tasha: 是你的吗
Shure: 然后下一个
Tasha: 你喝水了吗
Lucia: 就这个也
Lucia: 其实也是压花
Tasha: 好好那就是你的
Tasha: 我的呢
Tasha: 不管了这瓶就是我的
Shure: 要不你拿着给大家展示一下
Shure: 呃我拿着来
Shure: 还是给大家展示一下吧
Shure: 这个会看的更
Lucia: 哎我把手机放哪了在这
Shure: 更那什么一点对
Shure: Make it a bit more like that, right?
Shure: 给大家看一下
Shure: Let me show you all.
其他人：他俩都买过了不管
Others: They've both bought it already, whatever.
Lucia: 这是什么呀
Lucia: What's this?
其他人： 我等他们有了我再买
Others: I'll wait until they have it, then I'll buy.
Shure: 对这是一个纯的海面
Shure: Yeah, this is a pure sea surface.
其他人：白手套吗
Others: White gloves?
其他人：给你上一套
Others: Let me give you a set.
Shure: 然后还有啊
Shure: And there's more.
其他人：你们不专业啊
Others: You guys aren't professional.
Shure: 还有这个
Shure: And there's this.
Shure: 这个是一个楼的
Shure: This is a building.
Shure: 还有这两个
Shure: And these two.
Shure: 仅剩
Shure: Only left.
其他人：纯景我们选择都是没有人的那种
Others: We choose pure scenery without people.
Shure: 对纯景的
Shure: Yeah, pure scenery.
其他人：我感觉有人那我就不太好
Others: I feel it's not good if there are people.
Shure: 那就先先拍一个楼的吧好吧
Shure: Let's shoot a building first, okay?
Tasha: 两个拍下看看
Tasha: Take a shot of both and see.
Shure: 这个楼的啊对
Shure: This building, right.
Shure: 一个大摩呃
Shure: A big tower, uh
Shure: 也不算摩天吧
Shure: Well, not exactly a skyscraper
Shure: 就是楼的一个井
Shure: Just a well in the building
Tasha: 拍下两个
Tasha: Buy two
Shure: 起拍价还是一个一个
Shure: Starting bid is still one each
其他人：两个
Others: Two
Shure: 两个
Shure: Two
Tasha: OK OK OK OK
Tasha: OK OK OK OK稳了稳了稳了稳了
Tasha: OK OK OK OK, steady, steady
Shure: 两个两次
Shure: Two, twice
Tasha: 我靠这资产阶级受不了了
Tasha: Oh man, this bourgeoisie, I can't handle it 社会问题
Shure: 你怎么都要买过来吗
Shure: Are you really going to buy it?
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Tasha: 真受不了了
Tasha: I really can't handle it
Shure: 三个三个一次
Shure: Three, three, once
Tasha: 我觉得三个是顶价
Tasha: I think three is the max price
Tasha: 下次我们直接拍三个
Tasha: Next time we bid three right away
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, twice
Tasha: 等有人说一个我们就说三个
Tasha: When someone says one, we say three
Tasha: 这样子就断层
Tasha: This way there's a gap
Shure: 露出了三三个三字
Shure: Revealed three, three
Tasha: 断层就不会有人买
Tasha: The gap makes it so no one buys
Tasha: 不过最后一个了怎么办
Tasha: But what about the last one?
Shure: 成交
Shure: Sold
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know
Shure: 还有最后一个
Shure: There's still one more
Tasha: 啊好好
Tasha: Ah, okay
Tasha: 好啊
Tasha: Alright
Shure: 这个是一个海的啊对
Shure: This one is a sea, right?
Shure: 它是个海的
Shure: It's a sea
Shure: 起拍价还是一个
Shure: Starting bid is still one
Tasha: 不是为什么有人吃了给我一个
Tasha: Why did someone eat it and give me one?
Shure: 一个
Shure: One
Jake:这要怎么卖啊
Jake: How do we sell this?
Jake:这个
Jake: This one
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: I don't know
Shure: 有人一个
Shure: Someone bids one
Jake:这要卖了给给他钱吧哈哈哈
Jake: If it sells, give them the money, haha
Shure: 两个两个一次
Shure: Two, two, once
Shure: 你就不要不要跟gas抢了好吗
Shure: Just don't compete with gas, okay?
Tasha: 三个
Tasha: Three.
Jake:他他他也乱分的是吧
Jake: He, he, he also divided them randomly, right?
Shure: 2个两次
Shure: Two, twice.
Tasha: 三个
Tasha: Three.
Shure: 3个一次
Shure: Three, once.
其他人：试吃一下
Others: Try it.
其他人：你现在一共多少个
Others: How many do you have now?
Jake:试试一下对
Jake: Try it, yeah.
其他人：我也试吃
Others: I'll try it too.
Shure: 3个3个
Shure: Three, three.
其他人：我一会儿帮你买一下姐
Others: I'll help you buy it later, sis.
Tasha: 好你就
Tasha: Sure, you just...
Shure: 3个一次啊
Shure: Three, once.
Tasha: 你就说出你的真实体验就行
Tasha: Just share your true experience.
Shure: 三个两次
Shure: Three, twice.
其他人：对对我已经体验过了
Others: Yeah, I've already experienced it.
Shure: 没事咱们咱们可以说着
Shure: It's okay, we can talk about it.
其他人：咱能不能吃饱了一会儿不想买了
Others: Can we eat until we're full? Otherwise, we won't want to buy it later.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Shure: 四个四个一次
Shure: Four, once.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
Shure: 四个两次
Shure: Four, twice.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Shure: 四个三次成交
Shure: Four, three times, deal.
其他人：算了吧算了吧
Others: Forget it, forget it.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Tasha: 买不到了算了
Tasha: Can't buy it now, forget it.
Lucia: 太急迫了太急迫了
Lucia: Too urgent, too urgent.
Lucia: 马上必须马上留
Lucia: Must leave immediately.
Tasha: 要不是把钱要不是替你还债了
Tasha: If only I hadn't paid off your debts.
Shure: OK变成大富翁了
Shure: OK, now you're a tycoon.
Shure: 富婆饿饿饭饭
Shure: Rich woman, starve, starve.
Tasha: 要不是要不是替你还债了
Tasha: If only, if only I hadn't paid off your debts.
Shure: 好的然后
Shure: Alright then...
Shure: 现在谁手上的比较少一点
Shure: Now, who has the least in their hand?
Tasha: 你有什么可拍的
Tasha: What do you have to shoot?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 还有12个你呢
Shure: Still 12, how about you?
Tasha: 还有12个
Tasha: Still 12.
Tasha: 我靠
Tasha: Oh my god.
其他人：你刚刚说的自我介绍
Others: You just talked about your self-introduction.
Shure: 6个
Shure: Six of them.
Tasha: 我就自我介绍
Tasha: I just introduced myself.
Tasha: 没有用啊
Tasha: It was useless.
其他人：你一共多少个
Others: How many in total?
Shure: 那黄导你先上来介绍一下你的拍品吧
Shure: Nicous, why don't you come up and introduce your auction item?
Tasha: 4个
Tasha: Four.
其他人：就4个
Others: Just four.
Tasha: 我替他还债了
Tasha: I paid off his debt.
Shure: 是中间这个相机吗
Shure: Is it this camera in the middle?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Alice:呀这玩意
Alice: Oh, this thing.
其他人：哈这个相机这个相机
Others: Haha, this camera, this camera.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Jake:你要要这相机我们直接起飞
Jake: If you want this camera, we'll take off right away.
Jake:哈哈哈一高币一高币
Jake: Hahaha, one high coin, one high coin.
Tasha: 好吧我我150个给你
Tasha: Okay, fine, I'll give you 150.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:直接起飞
Jake: Taking off right away.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 哈来吧来吧
Shure: Ha, come on, come on.
Shure: 黄岛黄岛先生
Shure: Mr. Director Nicous.
其他人： 哈哈哈一个EMO币买一个相机
Others: Hahaha, one EMO coin for a camera.
其他人：我今天还真没有什么拍品LUCIA好像完全忘记了跟我说这件事情
Others: I don't really have any auction items today. Lucia seemed to have completely forgotten to tell me about this.
Lucia: 我好像没跟他说这个事
Lucia: I think I didn't tell him about this.
其他人：是这个样子的呢
Others: That's how it is.
Alice:讲个故事
Alice: Tell a story.
Shure: 讲个故事
Shure: Tell a story.
Tasha: 是这个样子的呢
Tasha: That's how it is.
Alice:哎不对这是拍卖会
Alice: Wait, this is an auction.
Lucia: 我因为我自己因为我自己忘了
Lucia: Because I, because I forgot myself.
Jake:表表演一下没关系哈
Jake: It's okay, just perform.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Tasha: 是这个样子的呢
Tasha: That's how it is.
Shure: 还可以拍卖
Shure: It can still be auctioned.
Tasha: 是这个样子的呢
Tasha: That's how it is.
Lucia: 你你你不是还有瓶水吗
Lucia: Don't you still have a bottle of water?
Tasha: 是这个样子的呢
Tasha: Yeah, that's how it is.
Jake:哈哎好可以
Jake: Haha, alright, that's fine.
Lucia: 你不是还有瓶水吗
Lucia: Don't you still have a bottle of water?
Tasha: 是这个样子的天呐
Tasha: Oh my god, that's how it is.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:完了和和市场接轨了现在哈哈
Jake: Well, now we're in sync with the market, haha.
其他人：好好好我们已经市场化了哈
Others: Alright, alright, we've already been marketized, haha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: 他这有一瓶我们这都没有的饮料
Shure: He has a drink that we don't have.
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 起拍价一个
Shure: Starting bid is one.
Shure: 没有没有那个
Shure: No, no, not that.
Jake:你后面的是不是i
Jake: Is the one behind you an iPhone?
Shure: 我我靠
Shure: I, I... damn.
Shure: 这也是你的
Shure: This is yours too?
Tasha: 这是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Shure: 要不这样吧
Shure: How about this?
Shure: 那个给大家一起我们拍一组照片
Shure: Let's all take a group photo.
Lucia: 个
Lucia: A...
Tasha: 我说那一瓶
Tasha: I meant that bottle.
Tasha: 你确定你喝的这瓶是你的吧
Tasha: Are you sure the bottle you're drinking is yours?
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Tasha: 行那我就喝这瓶
Tasha: Okay, then I'll drink this bottle.
Lucia: 啊他擅长
Lucia: Ah, he excels.
Shure: 对来吧
Shure: Yes, let's do it.
Shure: 也算是卖了一波艺
Shure: Consider it a performance.
Tasha: 买什么
Tasha: Performance?
其他人：拍个照片
Others: Let's take a photo.
Shure: 怎么怎么拍
Shure: How do we take it?
Shure: 你可以定时下或者是怎么着
Shure: You can use a timer or something.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
其他人：然后给他拍一组写真哦
Others: Then take a set of portraits for him.
Tasha: 我靠还可以还真
Tasha: Damn, that's possible.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
Jake:可能是吧
Jake: Maybe.
Jake:看一下吧没有就算了
Jake: Let's have a look. If not, forget it.
Tasha: 露西卡这位朋友好大呀
Tasha: Lucia's friend is so big!
Jake:看一下看一下
Jake: Take a look, take a look.
其他人：大家稍微聚拢一点吧
Others: Everyone, gather around a bit.
Tasha: 是这样子的呢
Tasha: That's how it is.
Tasha: 耶哈哈
Tasha: Yay, haha.
Lucia: 好有点有点背光
Lucia: Oh, it's a bit backlit.
其他人：哦逆光还是到我这边来
Others: Oh, it's backlit, come over to my side.
其他人：啊这边要把椅子调个了可
Others: Ah, we need to adjust the chair over here.
其他人：没有没有是
Others: No, no, it's...
其他人：站到那个椅子的前面去吗嗯
Others: Should we stand in front of the chair? Hmm.
其他人：那要把椅子调个了
Others: Then we need to adjust the chair.
其他人：因为感觉有些人坐着比较好
Others: Because it feels better for some to sit.
Lucia: 哦对对要不然话大家可能就会
Lucia: Oh, right, otherwise everyone might...
Shure: 来来来老板c位
Shure: Come on, come on, Jake, center stage.
其他人：把把椅子撂饿了
Others: Move the chair over here.
其他人：把椅子转过来
Others: Turn the chair around.
其他人：有些人就就哎呀坐起来
Others: Some people, oh, sit down.
Alice:有人坐着有人站着
Alice: Some are sitting, some are standing.
Alice:不很像那种家族
Alice: It doesn't feel like a family.
其他人：我那我往后面站
Others: I'll stand in the back.
其他人：我往后面站
其他人：这还坐到
Others: Still sitting here.
其他人：坐的人还坐到这
Others: The ones sitting are still here.
Jake:guys的先坐行吗
Jake: Guys, sit down first, okay?
其他人：不是他过来他全会在人脸上
Others: No, if he comes over, he'll be in everyone's face.
其他人：之前都谁做的就做呗
Others: Whoever sat here before, just sit.
其他人：是之前一张网布是挡住的
Others: It was blocked by a net before.
Shure: 哦哦
Shure: Oh, oh.
其他人：还坐着
Others: Still sitting.
其他人：你搞一个全白的
Others: You need a completely white one.
Jake:盖子先坐
Jake: Sit down first.
Shure: 纯白的是吗
Shure: Completely white, right?
Jake:然后就是志愿者往后坐
Jake: Then volunteers sit in the back.
其他人：对
Others: Yes.
其他人：或者或者直接给他断
Others: Or just cut it off.
其他人：掉全纯黑的
Others: Make it completely black.
Jake:盖子先往前坐
Jake: Sit in the front first.
Shure: 纯黑的哦
Shure: Completely black, oh.
其他人：啊其实只有第二排对你之后加一点
Others: Ah, actually only the second row, then add a bit more for you later.
Shure: 弄个纯黑的
Shure: Make it all black.
Tasha: 然后空白的对
Tasha: And then leave it blank, right.
Jake:好那前面三个椅子都干掉是吧挪掉
Jake: Okay, so we get rid of the first three chairs, right? Move them away.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 可以可以
Tasha: That's fine, that's fine.
其他人：什么环节
Others: What part is this?
Tasha: 拍拍合照
Tasha: Taking group photos.
Jake:来请坐请坐请坐请坐请坐请坐
Jake: Come on, have a seat, have a seat, have a seat, have a seat, have a seat.
其他人：你本来最高
Others: You were originally the tallest.
Shure: 你本来最高
其他人：然后就还给自己夹棒上
Others: Then just add some weight to yourself.
Shure: 然后就还给自己加磅是吧
Shure: Then just add some weight to yourself, right?
Tasha: 你本来就最高
Tasha: You were already the tallest.
其他人：没有没有他最高
Others: No, no, he's the tallest.
Jake:请坐请坐请坐请坐请坐
Jake: Have a seat, have a seat, have a seat, have a seat, have a seat.
Shure: 呀真好看
Shure: Wow, it looks really good.
Tasha: 行哦耶
Tasha: Alright, oh yeah.
Lucia: 呀你怎么这么高哈
Lucia: Wow, why are you so tall?
其他人：我都没人坐
Others: Nobody is sitting here.
Tasha: 我踩了个椅子
Tasha: I'm standing on a chair.
Jake:请坐请坐
Jake: Have a seat, have a seat.
Jake:3位客人请坐
Jake: Three guests, please sit.
其他人：前面坐着
Others: Sit in the front.
其他人：后面有人站着
Others: People are standing in the back.
其他人：有点像那种家族照片像一
Others: It's a bit like those family photos.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Shure: 老板老板老板来来来
Shure: Boss, boss, boss, come here, come here, come here.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
其他人：老板坐中间
Others: Boss, sit in the middle.
Jake:老板站后面
Jake: Boss stands in the back.
Jake:老板照很远就好了
Jake: Boss, just stand far away, that's fine.
其他人：哦你也得过来
Others: Oh, you need to come over too.
Lucia: 福星你这个相机有自动那个什么吗
Lucia: Fuxing, does your camera have an automatic setting or something?
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
其他人：没买没没花出去
Others: Didn't buy it, didn't spend the money.
Jake:有三脚架有三脚架
Jake: There's a tripod, there's a tripod.
其他人：但是有三 脚架
Others: But there's a tripod.
其他人：
Others:
Jake:对我们三脚架多得很
Jake: We have plenty of tripods.
Tasha: 拍的到拍的到
Tasha: We can film it, we can film it.
Tasha: 不要不要哈哈哈
Tasha: No, no, hahaha.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哎现在可以哦
Lucia: Hey, it's okay now.
Lucia: 不可以你是没那个啥了
Lucia: No, you can't, you don't have that thing.
Alice:我打你吗
Alice: Should I hit you?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
其他人：这三脚架一直没用上其他人：
Others: This tripod hasn't been used at all.
其他人：没用上就等你呢
Others: We were waiting for you.
Shure: 哈哈哈就等你呢
Shure: Hahaha, we were waiting for you.
其他人：我们算到了其实
Others: We actually anticipated this.
Tasha: 就站这就行
Tasha: Just stand here, it's fine.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Alice:我我我狗的老老婆呢
Alice: Where's my old dog wife?
Jake:哈哈在这蹲俩是吧
Jake: Hahaha, squatting here, right?
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 可以让他们加进来
Lucia: We can let them join.
Jake:拍不到吧
Jake: Can't film that, right?
Shure: 让他俩让他俩也进来
Shure: Let those two come in too.
Lucia: 可以吗他俩在前面
Lucia: Is it okay? They're in front.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Jake:嗯挺好
Jake: Hmm, pretty good.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Jake:这边
Jake: Over here.
Lucia: 要不咱俩换一下那个啥因为
Lucia: How about we switch that thing because...
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Alice:没事
Alice: It's fine.
Lucia: 这样可以在
Lucia: This way it can...
其他人：你想过了就来吧别太矜持了
Others: If you've thought it through, just come over, don't be too shy.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia: 你在这边
Lucia: You stay here.
Alice:我打不着你了是吧哈哈哈
Alice: I can't hit you now, right? Hahaha.
Lucia: 然后我们可以这样哈
Lucia: And then we can do it like this, ha.
其他人：见证见证
Others: Witness, witness.
其他人：一对一对新人
Others: A pair of newlyweds
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
其他人：哈哈哈行
Others: Hahaha alright
Lucia: 1对新人一对新狗哈哈哈
Lucia: A pair of newlyweds and a pair of new dogs haha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 你的狗戴花花
Lucia: Your dog is wearing flowers
Alice:你的狗戴红花
Alice: Your dog is wearing a red flower
Lucia: 你的狗才是新娘
Lucia: Your dog is the bride
Alice:你的狗才是新娘哈哈哈
Alice: Your dog is the bride hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
其他人：别说他脸红
Others: Don't say it, he's blushing
其他人：感谢你特别邀请
Others: Thank you for the special invitation
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Alice:哈感谢你特别邀请哈哈哈
Alice: Haha, thank you for the special invitation hahaha
其他人： 太眼红了
Others: Too jealous
Tasha: 拍卖结束之后干嘛呀
Tasha: What do we do after the auction?
其他人：之后可能是看房间
Others: After that, we might look at the rooms
Tasha: 哦对对对
Tasha: Oh right, right
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：然后就是5点多钟就开始大party
Others: Then around 5 o'clock, we start the big party
其他人：就是吃吃喝喝什么的哦
Others: Just eating and drinking and stuff
Tasha: 点披萨对
Tasha: Order pizza, right
Tasha: 然后就结束了
Tasha: Then it's over
其他人：然后还会有唱歌跳舞哦
Others: And there will be singing and dancing
Jake:后面没开
Jake: The back is not open
Alice:后来后宫罪不容诛
Alice: Later, the harem will be punished
Shure: 就就放这些吧
Shure: Just, just play these
Shure: 那个放白的那个有点就是照到脸上了
Shure: The white one, it's kind of shining on the face
Lucia: 咱这甚至还有补光灯呢不虚
Lucia: We even have fill lights, no worries
其他人：可以啊
Others: That's great
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey
其他人：补光灯嘛
Others: Fill lights, huh
其他人：这没必要
Others: Not necessary
Alice:对不起
Alice: Sorry
Jake:补光灯要到前面的
Jake: The fill lights should be at the front
其他人： 暂时暂时不用了
Others: For now, we don't need it
Jake:还不用啊
Jake: Not yet?
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay
Jake:雨轩拿
Jake: Yuxuan, take it.
Jake:可以拿一个眼镜
Jake: You can take a pair of glasses.
Jake:你可以不戴你
Jake: You don't have to wear them.
小 其他人：
Others:
其他人：你们买了这个就和我姐间接的联系
Others: If you buy this, you'll indirectly connect with my sister.
Jake:也可以
Jake: That's fine too.
其他人：好 10秒自拍模式啊
Others: Alright, 10-second selfie mode.
Tasha: 其他人：
Tasha: Others:
Shure: 这一幕好像好似曾相识
Shure: This scene feels so familiar.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
Shure: 来吧我觉得这波的才艺
Shure: Come on, I think this performance...
Jake:很有才艺
Jake: It's very talented.
Shure: 123456
Shure: 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Jake:黄一波黄一波
Jake: Huang Yibo, Huang Yibo.
Tasha: 是吧
Tasha: Right?
Jake:挺好的
Jake: Pretty good.
Shure: 6吧
Shure: It's great.
Jake:呵行
Jake: Ha, alright.
其他人：再来点发发发发哈哈
Others: Do it again, ha ha.
Shure: 大家搬搬下凳子
Shure: Everyone, move your chairs.
Shure: 然后回到原位
Shure: And return to your seats.
Shure: 然后我们继续进行这个拍卖环节
Shure: Then we'll continue with the auction segment.
Tasha: 还有谁
Tasha: Who else?
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 谢宾主呢
Shure: Thanks to the host.
Shure: 谢宾主点
Shure: Thanks to the host's point.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Tasha: 点什么呀
Tasha: What should I order?
Tasha: 披萨达美乐吗
Tasha: Domino's pizza?
Tasha: 嗯蘸点
Tasha: Hmm, dip.
Tasha: 啊蘸点披萨啊
Tasha: Ah, dip the pizza.
Tasha: 行蘸点披萨
Tasha: Alright, dip the pizza.
Tasha: 有特别大的那种哦
Tasha: There's a really big one.
Jake:披萨大披萨
Jake: Large pizza.
Alice:干嘛老公动手动脚的
Alice: Hey, why are you being so handsy?
Jake:超级大披萨
Jake: Super large pizza.
Alice:这是大庭广众
Alice: We're in public.
Alice:刘婷你的够花吗
Alice: Liu Ting, do you have enough money?
Alice:要不我给你偷俩哈哈哈
Alice: Should I steal a couple for you? Haha.
其他人：谁会先把那年APP下载一下
Others: Who will download that APP first?
Alice:哈哈哈我去偷粮哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha I'm going to steal some food hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人：你怎么点
Others: How do you order?
Lucia: 你在check吗
Lucia: Are you checking?
其他人：那个跑腿啊
Others: That delivery service
Lucia: 让我看看
Lucia: Let me see
Tasha: 怎么点
Tasha: How to order
Tasha: 你买了吗
Tasha: Did you buy it?
Tasha: 还没买那你就想点跑腿
Tasha: Haven't bought it yet and you want to order delivery
Lucia: 哎好看哎
Lucia: Hey, it looks nice
其他人：哈哈哈先先点
Others: Hahaha just order first
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人：如此平静的对
Others: So calm about it
其他人：跟你的对话透露着他的无奈
Others: His conversation with you reveals his helplessness
其他人：扫码点餐
Others: Scan to order
其他人：我自己来选
Others: I'll choose by myself
Tasha: 刚帮人拍了个照就有8个EGO港币
Tasha: Just helped someone take a photo and got 8 EGO Hong Kong dollars
Tasha: 哈哈啊他
Tasha: Haha, he
Tasha: 他刚刚还打压我们的市场价
Tasha: He just suppressed our market price
Tasha: 为什么我们才两个
Tasha: Why do we only get two
Tasha: 一个一个币
Tasha: One coin each
Tasha: 两个就是
Tasha: Two is
其他人：薄利多销
Others: Small profit, quick turnover
其他人：最大最大的那个
Others: The biggest one
其他人： 你一会一个一个卖
Others: You sell one by one later
Shure: 点
Shure: Order
其他人：我给你我给你一个一个来
Others: I'll give you, I'll give you one by one
Shure: 24的话 24的话咱们是几个人十
Shure: If it's 24, how many people do we have, ten
Lucia: 啊那我得坚持10秒吗
Lucia: Ah, do I have to hold on for 10 seconds?
Tasha: 我我只收20%的佣金
Tasha: I'll only charge 20% commission
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 先点一个
Shure: Order one first
Shure: 然后再点点别的吧
Shure: Then order something else
Tasha: 可以点个榴莲的吗
Tasha: Can we order a durian one?
Lucia: 好久表情都不自然了
Lucia: The expression hasn't been natural for a while
Tasha: 点个榴莲的吧
Tasha: Order a durian one
Lucia: 你看后面又过坡哈哈
Lucia: Look, another slope behind haha
Shure: 点
Shure: Order
Tasha: 不点跑腿了
Tasha: No more delivery
Shure: 了
Shure: Okay
其他人：为啥为啥不点跑腿
Others: Why, why don't we use a delivery service?
其他人：手机在我手你急什么
Others: The phone is in my hand, why are you so anxious?
Shure: 点了点了
Shure: I already did, I already did.
Tasha: 呵呵呵呵
Tasha: Hehehehe.
Alice:露西亚我想跟你合照一张
Alice: Lucia, I want to take a picture with you.
Alice:好呀哎呀哎呀呦呦呦
Alice: Sure, oh my, oh my, oh my.
Lucia: 哈哈只要有复兴出现的地方
Lucia: Haha, wherever there's a revival.
Lucia: 他就会变成摄影师哈哈哈
Lucia: He becomes the photographer, haha.
Alice:真好哈
Alice: That's great, haha.
Shure: 你增加点囤货吗
Shure: Are you stocking up more?
Tasha: 怎么可能没有
Tasha: How could there be none?
Lucia: sorry sorry sorry my fault
Lucia: Sorry, sorry, sorry, my fault.
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 要不要把它转一下打到脸上
Lucia: Do you want to rotate it to hit the face?
Alice:哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: 我们站这边的话可以调
Lucia: If we stand here, we can adjust it.
Alice:我们站这边了
Alice: We are standing here now.
其他人：我觉得夏威夷的可以
Others: I think the Hawaiian one is good.
Lucia: 其实可以调一下
Lucia: Actually, it can be adjusted.
Lucia: 让他给脸上补点光之类的
Lucia: Let him add some light on the face or something.
Tasha: 夏威夷的不好吃
Tasha: Hawaiian isn't tasty.
其他人：带点特色
Others: It has some special features.
Tasha: 从开始
Tasha: From the start.
其他人：我搜一下这个什么垃圾桶
Others: I'll search for this, what kind of trash can?
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What?
其他人：靠搜不着
Others: Can't find it.
Tasha: 不好搜呀
Tasha: It's hard to search for.
Tasha: 看看看看
Tasha: Look, look, look.
其他人：耶
Others: Yay.
Tasha: 耶
Tasha: Yay.
其他人：哎
Others: Hey.
Tasha: 24英寸 10英寸
Tasha: 24 inches, 10 inches.
Tasha: 24英寸 14英寸这太
Tasha: 24 inches, 14 inches, that's too...
Lucia: 哎可以好看
Lucia: Hey, it looks good.
Alice:谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha: 大了点一个就够了吧
Tasha: It's a bit big, one should be enough, right?
Shure: 好好好
Shure: Okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 可以可以
Lucia: It’s okay, it's okay.
Alice:我我我不太会拍
Alice: I... I... I'm not good at taking photos.
其他人：对就点一个哦
Others: Yeah, just click one.
Tasha: 就点一个
Tasha: Just click one.
Tasha: 那不能点榴莲的吧
Tasha: But we can't choose durian, right?
Tasha: 就点这个吧
Tasha: Just pick this one.
Tasha: 蘸点特色披萨吧
Tasha: Let's dip it in some special pizza.
其他人：蘸点特色披萨啊
Others: Dip it in some special pizza.
其他人：垃圾桶
Others: Trash can.
Tasha: 垃圾桶啊
Tasha: Trash can.
Tasha: 真的吗
Tasha: Really?
Lucia: 哇你怎么带这么奇装备
Lucia: Wow, why did you bring such weird gear?
Alice:我是点这个就可以是吗
Alice: Is it okay if I just click this?
其他人：双倍奶酪6-12人
Others: Double cheese for 6-12 people.
Tasha: 不要双倍奶酪了吧
Tasha: No double cheese, right?
Tasha: 一个吧一个个吧
Tasha: Just one, just one.
Alice:来吧
Alice: Come on.
Tasha: 就点一个吧
Tasha: Just pick one.
其他人：还要点什么串
Others: What else should we order?
Tasha: 还有甜品呢
Tasha: There's dessert too.
Tasha: 不要不要不要
Tasha: No, no, no.
Tasha: 一次性餐你觉得
Tasha: Single-use tableware, what do you think?
Tasha: 不是不是要注册吗
Tasha: Don't we need to register?
Shure: 来吧现在我们下一位拍卖者
Shure: Alright, now let's welcome our next auctioneer.
Tasha: 一定要注册
Tasha: You must register.
Tasha: 然后然后你还要点
Tasha: And then, you still have to order.
Tasha: 你不要餐具哦对啊
Tasha: You don't need utensils, right?
Tasha: 店内自取啊
Tasha: Pick up in store.
Tasha: 打包打包带走对
Tasha: Take away, right.
Tasha: 这是什么店
Tasha: What kind of store is this?
Tasha: 我看等一下啊
Tasha: Let me see, wait a second.
其他人：本次拍卖的东西主要是有两个
Others: The items for this auction mainly include two things.
其他人：第一个呢是一盒口服的牙线棒
Others: The first one is a box of oral floss sticks.
Tasha: 你还帮他升签了呀
Tasha: You even helped him upgrade the visa?
其他人：为什么要选择这个呢
Others: Why choose this?
其他人：主要是因为有一句老话叫什么叫
Others: Mainly because there's an old saying, what's it called...
Tasha: 你猜他你猜他拿了啥
Tasha: Guess what he took, guess.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 他拿了个牙签
Tasha: He took a toothpick.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Tasha: 我的发
Tasha: My hair...
Tasha: 哇 32寸
Tasha: Wow, 32 inches!
Shure: 我自己哈
Shure: Just me, haha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Tasha: 这好不错
Tasha: This is pretty nice.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
其他人：买这个
Others: Buy this one!
Tasha: 买这个
Tasha: Buy this one.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Shure: 哈哈
Shure: Haha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Tasha: 送我先买
Tasha: Deliver to me first, I'll buy it.
其他人：所以呢对这个对这个牙齿的健康
Others: So, about the health of your teeth...
Tasha: 然后他会配送
Tasha: And then he will deliver...
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha
Tasha: 他不配送
Tasha: He won't deliver.
其他人：口腔健康对我们来说是格外的重要的
Others: Oral health is especially important to us.
Tasha: 那就那就
Tasha: Then, just...
Tasha: 那你就打电话跟他说帮我核销一下
Tasha: Then you call and tell him to cancel it for me.
其他人：所以这就是作为我们的第一件拍卖品
Tasha: 等会找人去拿哦嗯
Tasha: I'll find someone to pick it up later, okay.
其他人：我们从一个币开始拍
Others: We'll start the bidding at one coin.
其他人：一个OK哈哈哈
Others: One coin, okay, hahaha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：一个币一个币还有吗
Others: One coin, one coin, anyone else?
Jake:这就是传媒人吧
Jake: This is just media people.
Tasha: 你就买然后我跟他说帮我核销掉
Tasha: You just buy it, and I'll tell him to cancel it for me.
其他人：什么招手
Others: What, a wave?
其他人：5个币是吗哈哈哈
Others: Five coins, right? Hahaha.
Tasha: 我现在找人来拿就行了
Tasha: I'll find someone to pick it up now.
其他人：要不你搞吧
Others: Why don't you handle it?
其他人：一个币一个币一次
Others: One coin, one coin, once.
其他人：我累了
Others: I'm tired.
Tasha: 不是我点了多少次餐了
Tasha: Haven't I ordered enough times already?
Shure: 算了算了
Shure: Forget it, forget it.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 一个币两次
Shure: One coin, two tries.
其他人：我去点烤肠不
Other: Shall I go order some grilled sausages?
Alice:5个币是吧
Alice: Is it 5 coins?
Tasha: 你你付过了
Tasha: You've already paid.
Alice:我都没有
Alice: I haven't paid.
Tasha: 你付了呀
Tasha: You did pay.
Alice:我跟你讲
Alice: I'm telling you...
其他人：我付我付我付
Other: I'll pay, I'll pay, I'll pay.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
其他人：OK一币三次
Other: Okay, three tries per coin.
其他人：恭喜你哈哈
Other: Congrats! Haha.
Lucia: 恭喜你太好了
Lucia: Congrats! That's awesome.
Lucia: 哈哈哈啊对
Lucia: Hahaha, right.
其他人：内不消化啊
Other: That's not digestible.
其他人：对把币给我
Other: Yeah, give me the coins.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
其他人：然后拿花呗
Other: Then use Huabei.
Lucia: 就当就当是他拍的
Lucia: Let's just say it's his treat.
Lucia: 因为他那个小狗没跟我收钱哈哈哈
Lucia: Because his puppy didn't charge me, hahaha.
Tasha: 花呗哦
Tasha: Huabei, oh.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 你知道今天健康
Tasha: You know today's health...
Tasha: 他
Tasha: He...
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Tasha: 他用美团
Tasha: He uses Meituan.
Shure: 亲兄弟明算账是吧
Shure: Brothers clear accounts, right?
Tasha: 一直用美团月付你知道吗
Tasha: He's been using Meituan installment, you know?
Tasha: 嗯然后你知道他钱多少
Tasha: And you know how much money he has?
Tasha: 嗯他把他那个美团月付刷爆了
Tasha: He's maxed out his Meituan installment.
其他人：在身无分文的年纪遇见了最想要的啥
Other: Meeting what you want most while being broke.
其他人：大概多少
Other: About how much?
其他人：牙线棒是吗哈哈
Other: Floss sticks, right? Haha.
Tasha: 2,000 哈哈
Tasha: 2,000, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
其他人：我操我得等一下
Other: Damn, I need a moment.
其他人：我得用微信买
Other: I need to use WeChat to buy it.
其他人：接下来是我们第二个
Other: Next is our second...
其他人：我们美团吧
Other: Let's use Meituan.
其他人：美团呢
Other: Meituan, right?
其他人：问题是一本书叫月亮和六
Other: The question is, there's a book called "The Moon and Sixpence."
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
Tasha: 他带了多少杂七杂八的东西
Tasha: How many random things did he bring?
Tasha: 一个EGO比一个EGO币卖
Tasha: One EGO for one EGO coin.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Alice:你从哪偷的
Alice: Where did you steal it from?
Alice:你跟我说说
Alice: Tell me.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Tasha: 这没有
Tasha: There's no...
其他人：有这么一本书啊
Other: There really is such a book.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
其他人：俗话说得好啊
Other: As the saying goes...
Shure: 我好一脸懵
Shure: I'm so confused.
其他人：这个书籍是人类进步的阶梯
Other: Books are the ladder of human progress.
其他人：这个应该不是我说的啊
Other: That wasn't my line, though.
其他人：那我们是
Other: So we are...
Shure: 这是高尔基说的
Shure: That was Gorky who said that.
其他人：那我们这个第二个产品起步价盈利
Other: So our second product's starting price is profit.
其他人：一个币
Other: One coin.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahahahahahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人：哈哈哈一个币一次
Other: Hahaha, one coin each time.
Shure: 这绝版的这书都
Shure: This book is out of print.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人：哈哈哈这个是月亮和六便士哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha, this is "The Moon and Sixpence," hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 我看看这到底是谁
Shure: Let me see who this actually is.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha.
Shure: 是
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 吧
Shure: Right.
其他人：应该是吧
Others: It should be, right?
其他人：就是一个看起来很像盗版的正版书
Others: It's like a genuine book that looks like a pirated copy.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahaha.
其他人：满地都是月亮
Others: The ground is full of moons.
其他人：他在抬头看见6便士
Others: He looks up and sees sixpence.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha.
Lucia: 你冷静一点
Lucia: Calm down.
其他人：一个币两次
Others: Two coins for once.
其他人：2个币OK
Others: Two coins, okay.
其他人：OK两个币一次
Others: Okay, two coins for once.
其他人：这么顺利的待会书都给我拿走了
Others: If it's that smooth, take all the books for me later.
Alice:哈哈哈两个币两次
Alice: Haha, two coins, twice.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 没有没有
Shure: No, no.
其他人：两个币两次哦
Others: Two coins, twice.
Jake:次
Jake: Times.
Shure: 谢云珠出3个币
Shure: Xie Yunzhu bids three coins.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Shure: 谢云珠出3
Shure: Xie Yunzhu bids three.
Tasha: 他出3个币
Tasha: He bids three coins.
其他人：他出3个币
Others: He bids three coins.
其他人：3个币 3个币一次
Others: Three coins, three coins once.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
其他人：这个错版书
Others: This misprinted book.
其他人：错版书啊
Others: Misprinted book, huh.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
其他人：3个币两次
Others: Three coins, twice.
Alice:hahahaha
Alice: Hahahaha.
其他人：OK三个币成交
Others: Okay, three coins, deal.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：谢云竹拿钱
Others: Xie Yunzhu, take the money.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahahaha.
Shure: 银行突然多了3块钱的
Shure: Suddenly there's 3 more bucks in the bank
Lucia: 突然负债三个
Lucia: Suddenly 3 bucks in debt
其他人：恭喜你
Others: Congratulations
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
其他人：赚钱了姐
Others: You're making money, sis
其他人：读点书读点书
Others: Read more books, read more books
其他人：为啥为什么错版
Others: Why, why is it a misprint
Shure: 因为月亮和六便士
Shure: Because of "The Moon and Sixpence"
其他人：因为月亮和月亮河就不愿意
Others: Because of the moon, and the Moon River just doesn't want to
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahaha
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 哦谢飞竹觉得还挺对的哈哈哈
Shure: Oh, Xie Feizhu thinks it's quite right, hahaha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
其他人：月亮与六便士
Others: The Moon and Sixpence
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 对
Shure: Right
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Shure: 来吧来吧 3个币
Shure: Come on, come on, 3 coins
Lucia: 从公家出啊
Lucia: From the public fund, huh
其他人：他有啊
Others: He has it
aw他给了他给了他给了是吗
Others: Oh, he gave it, he gave it, did he?
Shure: 啊他给了是吧
Shure: Ah, he gave it, right?
Shure: 啊啊我以为他
Shure: Ah, I thought
Alice:别说出来
Alice: Don't say it out loud
Tasha: 点了吗
Tasha: Did you order?
Alice:你这不偷偷拿6个
Alice: Aren't you secretly taking 6?
Alice:你给我呀
Alice: Give it to me
Shure: 他从他从世界银行走的
Shure: He left, he left from the World Bank
Shure: 我以为
Shure: I thought
Tasha: 点了吗披萨
Tasha: Did you order pizza?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Alright
Lucia: 怒转六个
Lucia: Transfer 6 angrily
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
其他人：我们是核销
Others: We are canceling it.
Shure: 我们下一位没了吧是吧
Shure: We don't have the next one, right?
Alice:这得值俩币
Alice: This should be worth two coins.
Tasha: 我打电话给他
Tasha: I'll call him.
Shure: 还有还有
Shure: There's more, there's more.
Tasha: 你不想打电话是吧
Tasha: You don't want to call, right?
Tasha: 我想打你可以打呀
Tasha: I want to call, you can call.
Shure: 小杜
Shure: Xiaodu
Tasha: 那你不在抖音买啊
Tasha: Then why don't you buy it on Douyin?
其他人：我从学校干了个钥匙链
Others: I got a keychain from school.
其他人：买好了抖音哦
Others: Bought it on Douyin.
其他人：我要在抖音打电话
Others: I'm going to make a call on Douyin.
其他人：行政预言钥匙链
Others: Administrative prophecy keychain.
Tasha: 哎呦我的妈呀我真受不了你了
Tasha: Oh my god, I can't stand you.
其他人：好好我就要拍了好这
Others: Alright, alright, I'm going to film it now.
Tasha: 好什么东西啊
Tasha: Alright, what is this?
其他人：形胜遗言钥匙链
Others: Victory legacy keychain.
其他人：虽然我这个
Others: Even though this...
其他人：这个在全市跟我半年
Others: Stayed with me for half a year in the city.
其他人：积攒了那个各种我姐夫代码的怨恨
Others: Accumulated various resentments from my brother-in-law's codes.
其他人：然后我大早上骂人的那个语气
Others: And my morning cursing tone.
其他人：还有我放过那个下班回家的开心
Others: And the joy of going home after work.
其他人：还有在学校里的自由的气息
Others: And the breath of freedom in school.
其他人：那拿到之后就想到了
Others: After getting it, I thought...
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
其他人：因为这上面有有有怨凝固的
Others: Because it has solidified grudges on it.
其他人：有怨灵的
Others: It has vengeful spirits.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Tasha: 有怨灵的
Tasha: It has vengeful spirits.
Tasha: 什么东西啊
Tasha: What is this?
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：钥匙扣啊
Others: Keychain.
Tasha: 什么钥匙扣吧
Tasha: What keychain?
Lucia: 开过光了开过光
Lucia: It's been blessed.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
其他人：二校的钥匙
Others: The second school's key.
其他人：那个一个是清华校徽一个是二校门
Others: One is the Tsinghua University emblem, and the other is the Second Gate.
其他人：一个是那个日本的那个学校
Others: One is from that Japanese school.
Shure: OK
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Let's go
Shure: 那么我们现在开始一个币的起拍
Shure: Now we're starting the bidding for one coin.
Shure: 一个一个
Shure: One by one
Shure: l同学出一个一个币一次
Shure: Student L bids one coin, once.
Tasha: 我让他5分钟后到店
Tasha: I'll have him at the store in 5 minutes.
其他人：大概多少分钟到店
Others: About how many minutes to the store?
Tasha: 大概多长时间做好
Tasha: How long will it take to finish?
Shure: 艾鲁艾鲁同学出了两个
Shure: Elu Elu bids two.
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello?
Shure: 两个臂一次
Shure: Two coins, once.
Shure: 2个币两次
Shure: Two coins, twice.
其他人：怨念这么大的东西才两个币
Others: Such a big thing for just two coins.
Lucia: 两个币两次
Lucia: Two coins, twice.
其他人：这店里挺贵的
Others: This store is pretty expensive.
Lucia: 3个好3个
Lucia: Three, okay, three.
Shure: 3个3个币一次
Shure: Three coins, once.
Lucia: 3个币一次
Lucia: Three coins, once.
Shure: 主办有没有想想想想要的3个币的啊
Shure: Does the host want to bid three coins?
Alice:可以可以给我掏钱吗哈
Alice: Can you pay for me, haha?
Lucia: 超过了我的存款哈
Lucia: It's over my savings, haha.
Shure: 3个币一次
Shure: Three coins, once.
其他人：可以走世界银行给你贷个
Others: Maybe get a loan from the World Bank.
Shure: 3个币两次
Shure: Three coins, twice.
小其他人：世界银行贷点款
Others: World Bank loan.
Alice:哈哈我可以哇贷死你吗
Alice: Haha, I could get you loaned to death.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：我可以贷
Others: I can loan.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Shure: 我出4个
Shure: I'll bid four.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
Shure: 4个币一次4个币两次了
Shure: Four coins, once. Four coins, twice.
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
其他人：妈下拉 挂了
Others: Mom, hang on.
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow
Alice:老公给我买
Alice: Honey, buy it for me.
其他人：还蛮有意思的
Others: It's quite interesting.
Tasha: 怎么说了
Tasha: What do you mean?
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh my!
Alice:我我出了4个呀
Alice: I got four!
Lucia: 哇
Lucia: Wow!
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Shure: 5个币一次
Shure: 5 coins each time.
Alice:4个我出的呀
Alice: I got four!
Alice:你压我干啥
Alice: Why are you pressuring me?
Shure: 5个币两次
Shure: 5 coins for two times.
其他人：你有吗
Others: Do you have it?
Shure: 5个币3次
Shure: 5 coins for three times.
Alice:我没有我不能贷款吗
Alice: I don't have it, can't I take a loan?
Lucia: 没有
Lucia: No.
Tasha: 算了吧小程序点吧
Tasha: Forget it, just use the app.
其他人：不是我应
Others: It wasn't me.
其他人：该想好了
Others: Should have thought it through.
Shure: 成交
Shure: Deal.
Tasha: 你就问他你就跟
Tasha: Just ask him, just...
Tasha: 你就把那个码报给他
Tasha: Just give him the code.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
其他人：没有这一款
Others: There's no such version.
Tasha: 你就把这个码报给他
Tasha: Just give him the code.
其他人：我想我要不要哄抬物价来着
Others: I was thinking if I should inflate prices.
Tasha: 然后你说大概多长时间做好
Tasha: Then ask how long it'll take to finish.
Tasha: 行了
Tasha: Alright.
其他人：没事你从我这10个币买走
Others: No worries, buy it from me for 10 coins.
其他人：知道呀他不理我了
Others: You know, he ignored me.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 他人家就是那学校的哈哈哈
Shure: He's just from that school, hahaha
Lucia: 这才叫哄抬物价
Lucia: That's what you call price gouging.
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈二道贩子
Lucia: Hahaha, a middleman.
Lucia: 我为什么会需要这种道具啊
Lucia: Why would I need this kind of prop?
Tasha: 嗯没事
Tasha: Hmm, it's okay.
Shure: 还有还有奥
Shure: There's more, by the way.
Shure: 什么any auction animal
Shure: Something like any auction animal.
其他人：甜点还没卖呢姐姐
Others: The dessert hasn't been sold yet, sister.
Tasha: 不卖了
Tasha: Not selling anymore.
其他人： 不卖了
Others: Not selling anymore.
Tasha: 不知道不知道
Tasha: I don't know, I don't know.
Tasha: 随便吧姐啊啊
Tasha: Whatever, sis, ah ah.
Jake:卖卖卖卖卖
Jake: Sell, sell, sell, sell.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
其他人：所有吃过的都得叫你两声
Others: Everyone who has tried it must call you twice.
Shure: 啊大家可以看到啊
Shure: Ah, everyone can see it, right?
Tasha: 你来您来您来
Tasha: You go ahead, you go ahead.
其他人：我打咳嗽
Others: I have a cough.
Shure: 我们的大厨上来吧
Shure: Let's bring up our chef.
Shure: 来来我们的我们的
Shure: Come on, our, our...
Tasha: 来给我拿着
Tasha: Come, hold this for me.
Shure: 甜点甜点
Shure: Dessert, dessert.
Shure: king desert king还是desert king来着
Shure: Is it king dessert or desert king?
其他人：到店了我
Others: I'm at the shop.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
其他人：怎么我还要找骑手干嘛呀
Others: Why do I still need to find a rider?
Shure: desert还是desert desert吧
Shure: Desert or desert, it's desert, right?
Lucia: 啊这是太对了
Lucia: Ah, this is so right.
其他人：  我刚才都
Others: I just...
Lucia: 花钱花的太棒了
Lucia: Spending money is so awesome.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Lucia: 天呐
Lucia: Oh my god.
Lucia: 这个首先呢我们先征一下赔款
Lucia: First of all, let's collect some compensation.
Lucia: 就刚刚吃了
Lucia: Just now eaten.
Lucia: 先把币拿上来
Lucia: Bring the tokens up first.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Shure: 其他人：
Shure: Others:
其他人：销售我那个叫试吃
Others: Sales, I call it taste testing.
其他人：对对对我我是试吃
Others: Yes, yes, I was taste testing.
其他人：因为我是我是拍的
Others: Because I was filming.
其他人：：我是帮我姐拍的
Others: I was filming for my sister.
其他人：所以我刚先试吃一下
Others: So, I just tasted it first.
其他人：确保她的是正事
Others: To make sure it's authentic.
其他人：我已经试吃过
Others: I've already tasted it.
其他人：她确认是正事
Others: She confirmed it's authentic.
其他人：然后这个水果就可以不算
Others: And then the fruit can be excluded.
其他人：水果就不算了
Others: The fruit doesn't count.
其他人：这个这个吃了
Others: This, this has been eaten.
其他人：刚刚我们可以先按整整个一个币啊
Others: Just now, we could have pressed the whole coin.
其他人：然后交上来
Others: Then hand it over.
其他人：先交上来
Others: Hand it over first.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：刚刚谁这个币
Others: Who had this coin just now?
其他人：刚刚谁吃了
Others: Who ate it just now?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Alice:掉监控哈哈
Alice: Check the surveillance, haha.
其他人：24的呢
Others: What about the 24?
Jake:我有15台监控
Jake: I have 15 monitors.
其他人：大家我先把剩下卖完
Others: Everyone, I'll sell the rest first.
其他人：我们最后再来找这个人是是谁
Others: We'll find out who that person is last.
Shure: 其他人：
Shure: Others:
其他人：这个我吃了
Others: I ate this.
其他人：非常好吃
Others: It's really delicious.
其他人：这个东西它的价值在于
Others: The value of this thing is
其他人：抹茶粉非常的贵
Others: The matcha powder is very expensive.
其他人：以至于
Others: So,
其他人：撒抹茶粉和撒结的方法是不一样的
Others: Sprinkling matcha powder and sprinkling sugar are different methods.
其他人：呃它的味道的特点呢
Others: Uh, the characteristic of its taste is
其他人：在于很像日本的什么
Others: It's very similar to some Japanese...
其他人：什么抹茶
Others: Some kind of matcha.
其他人：反正就是非常的好吃
Others: Anyway, it's very delicious.
其他人：那我们起拍价就按一共只有两个
Others: So our starting bid is, considering there are only two,
其他人：所以
Others: So,
其他人：我们更希望它能成双成对的卖出去
Others: We hope they can be sold as a pair.
其他人：所以我们起拍价就按一个蛋挞一个币
Others: So our starting bid is one tart for one coin.
其他人：什么
Others: What?
其他人：一个蛋挞一个
Others: One tart for one...
其他人：抹茶抹茶比较贵
Others: Matcha is quite expensive.
Tasha: 最后一个蛋挞一个币
Tasha: The last tart for one coin.
Shure: 币一个蛋挞一个币
Shure: One coin for one tart.
Shure: 我真好饿呀
Shure: I'm really hungry.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Shure: 你先给我来一个
Shure: Give me one first.
awww3:拍拍拍起来
awww3: Bid, bid, bid!
Shure: 我出我出一个币
Shure: I'll bid one coin.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
其他人：有没有啊
Others: Is there any?
其他人：因为我们只有两个抹茶
Others: Because we only have two matcha.
其他人：剩下这些都比较多剩下这些都比较多
Others: The rest of these are quite a lot, the rest of these are quite a lot.
Shure: OK成交成交
Shure: OK, deal, deal.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Shure: 来吧给你一个币
Shure: Come on, here's a coin for you.
Shure: 我可以再
Shure: Can I
Shure: 拿一个吗
Shure: take another one?
其他人：：再拿一个就是另外价钱
Others: Taking another one will be a different price.
其他人：因为他现在已经只剩一个
Others: Because now there's only one left.
其他人：他就他等于要升级
Others: So it means you have to upgrade.
其他人：你先你先拿一个
Others: You take one first.
其他人：OK我先拿一个
Others: OK, I'll take one first.
其他人：：你先拿一个
Others: You take one first.
其他人：你可以考虑拿第二位
Others: You can consider taking the second one.
其他人：好那我们拍第二个
Others: Alright, then we'll take the second one.
其他人：因为他现在只剩一个
Others: Because now there's only one left.
其他人：所以我们可以附赠一个
Others: So we can throw in one for free.
其他人：你举着抹茶蛋挞拍照的机会可以吧
Others: You can take a photo holding the matcha tart, right?
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Shure: 其他人：
Shure: Others:
其他人：所以我这个
Others: So this one
其他人：可以附赠一个举着抹茶蛋挞拍照
Others: can be thrown in with a photo holding the matcha tart.
其他人：所以呢按理来说它应该价值两个币
Others: So logically speaking, it should be worth two coins.
其他人：那么还有一个币起拍
Others: Then it starts with one coin.
其他人：OK一个我喂就是例外的价钱
Others: OK, one coin is an exception price.
其他人：我也可以喂就是例外的价钱
Others: I can also make an exception for one coin.
其他人：哎好一个币还有没有别的了
Others: Hey, one coin, is there anything else?
其他人：一个币起开有人
Others: It starts with one coin, anyone?
其他人：再再点外卖
Others: Order takeout again.
其他人： 我又对不上你了
Others: I can't match up with you again.
其他人：还有吗
Others: Is there more?
其他人：没有只有一个币
Others: No, just one coin.
其他人：快那你那你嗖的一下
Others: Quick, you, you swoosh.
其他人：你之前是哦
Others: You were before, oh.
其他人：贯穿的可以说还是
Others: All the way through, you could say.
其他人：那你们那个够不够
Others: So, do you have enough?
其他人：来上来你可以跟他拍个照片啊
Others: Come on, you can take a photo with him.
Alice:个
Alice: A
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
其他人：我要和他合照
Others: I want to take a photo with him.
其他人：对你可以
Others: Yes, you can.
其他人：你可以他另外的是合照钱
Others: You can, but the rest is for the group photo fee.
Alice:币
Alice: Coin.
其他人：不是商品哦
Others: It's not a product.
其他人：商品和合照钱
Others: Product and group photo fee.
Shure: 你这有兜吗
Shure: Do you have a pocket?
其他人：只不过别人撑两个
Others: But others can hold two.
其他人：你跟他合照一个和这个和这个架子
Others: You take a photo with him, and this, and this stand.
其他人：他就装那个小盒子也装不了
Others: He can't even fit in the small box.
其他人：或者你想单独去拍他说
Others: Or if you want to take a solo shot, he said.
Lucia: 哎我把我手机扔哪了
Lucia: Hey, where did I throw my phone?
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈卖的是人家的可
Alice: Hahaha, selling is just someone else's...
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Shure: 哈
Alice:爱
Alice: Love.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Tasha: 哈有种帅哥明星甜品合照的感觉
Tasha: Haha, it feels like a handsome star dessert photo.
其他人：我们接下来要拍这个
Others: Next, we are going to shoot this.
其他人：这个是巧克力粉
Others: This is chocolate powder.
其他人：比较适合巧克力的重度爱好者
Others: More suitable for serious chocolate lovers.
其他人：虽然虽然我我就
Others: Although, although I...
Jake:和主厨握手的机会
Jake: A chance to shake hands with the chef.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
其他人：我就很喜欢吃这个所以它就剩了一个
Others: I just really like eating this, so there's only one left.
其他人：这个里面它的优势在于它有这个
Others: The advantage of this is that it has this...
其他人：这个巧克力豆比草莓就味道就不一样
Others: These chocolate chips taste different from strawberry.
其他人：  非常契合这个巧克力粉的设计理念
Others: They perfectly fit the design concept of this chocolate powder.
其他人：因为考虑到他也是孤品呢
Others: Considering it's also a single product.
其他人：就可以和主厨握一下手
Others: You can shake hands with the chef.
其他人：这个握手的价钱呢
Others: The price for shaking hands is...
其他人：另算呃但是呢
Others: Separate, but...
Shure: 只要你握手我们就碰到了合照的机会
Shure: As long as you shake hands, we get a photo opportunity.
Shure: 对吧
Shure: Right?
其他人：所以所以起拍价是一个币然后握手呢
Others: So, the starting price is one coin, and shaking hands...
其他人：哎一会坐下去吃哈哈哈
Others: Hey, let's sit down and eat later, hahaha.
其他人：我们当然我也可以单独开这个
Others: Of course, I can start this separately.
其他人：我也可以先不握手
Others: I can also choose not to shake hands first.
其他人：因为后面握手的机会还要很高
Others: Because there will be more chances for handshakes later
其他人：然后我们起拍价是一个币
Others: And our starting bid is one coin
其他人：快了别拍了
Others: Hurry up, stop bidding
其他人：然后大概搞一个结果
Others: And let's get a result
其他人：不要给我拍了吧
Others: Don't bid for me
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：大概40多分钟
Others: About 40 minutes
Shure: 一个币
Shure: One coin
其他人：40多分钟过去40多分钟过去40分钟过去
Others: 40 minutes have passed, 40 minutes have passed, 40 minutes have passed
Alice:你真的没有吗
Alice: Do you really not have it?
Shure: 牛币真的没有吗
Shure: Do you really not have any Niu coins?
Tasha: 40多分钟
Tasha: 40 minutes
Shure: 牛币一次
Shure: Niu coin, once
其他人：40多分钟过去
Others: 40 minutes have passed
其他人：40分钟
Others: 40 minutes
其他人：这个时候我们就要给内蒙人抢了钱
Tasha: 我给了他一个啊
Tasha: I gave him one already
Alice:吹蜡烛
Alice: Blow out the candles
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：找个这样的
Others: Find one like this
Shure: 我出我出我出一个币
Shure: I bid, I bid, I bid one coin
其他人：通州去九棵树
Others: Go to Jiukeshu in Tongzhou
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay
Tasha: 还要点什么烤串
Tasha: Do you want some skewers?
其他人：你给我一个币就可以了
Others: Just give me one coin
其他人：那你那你要和主厨握手啊
Others: Then you need to shake hands with the chef
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
其他人：我一会再握吧
Others: I'll shake later
其他人：一会再过那就是两个哈哈哈
Others: If you come back later, that'll be two, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
其他人：握手可以拍照
Others: You can take a photo while shaking hands
其他人：你还可以选择在那你不握手好了
Others: You can also choose to not shake hands there
Shure: 算了算了算了哈哈哈
Shure: Forget it, forget it, hahaha
Lucia: 其他人：
Lucia: Others:
Shure: 谢谢谢谢
Shure: Thank you, thank you
其他人：呃剩下的我们可以先拍这个麻薯
Others: Uh, we can start with filming this mochi
其他人：这个麻薯我们是做盒卖的
Others: This mochi is sold in boxes
其他人：这个我们就一个一盒一个币哦
Others: We're selling one box for one coin
其他人：因为这个麻薯属于西料制作
Others: Because this mochi is made with western ingredients
Katrina: 但是蛋挞它属于特别制作
Katrina: But the egg tart is specially made
其他人：而且蛋挞都是孤品
Others: And the egg tarts are all unique items.
其他人：麻薯它现在还不是孤品是市场调节的
Others: The mochi is not a unique item yet, it's market-adjusted.
其他人：这个第一个人买的是可以选的
Others: The first person to buy can choose.
其他人：第一个人买可以选这个和这个就后面
Others: The first person can choose between this and this, then after that...
其他人：比如说如果第一个人选了
Others: For example, if the first person chooses...
其他人：他后面就只有巧克力
Others: Then there's only chocolate left.
其他人：那个蛋挞应该这样
Others: The egg tart should be like this.
其他人：   我的臀部翘的可以顶起一瓶汽水
Others: My hips can lift a soda bottle.
其他人：
Others:
其他人：看好了一个币有没有加价的
Others: Look, there's no price increase for one coin.
其他人：都可以选口味
Others: You can choose the flavor.
其他人：这个口味
Others: This flavor...
其他人：是是是是是巧克力和
Others: Yes, yes, chocolate and...
其他人：巧克力和啥呀
Others: Chocolate and what?
Tasha: 豆乳
Tasha: Soy milk.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah...
Tasha: 豆乳好好
Tasha: Soy milk, okay.
其他人：好好OK OK
Others: Okay, okay.
其他人：豆腐豆腐
Others: Tofu, tofu.
Jake:2个
Jake: Two.
Shure: 其他人：
Shure: Others:
其他人：两个币可以选口味
Others: Two coins to choose the flavor.
其他人：这位先生
Others: Sir,
其他人：用两个币争取到选口味的机会
Others: Use two coins to get a chance to choose the flavor.
其他人：还有没有了
Others: Is there any more?
Lucia: 纸嗯哎我记得这里放了一包
Lucia: Paper, um, I remember putting a pack here.
其他人：好
Others: Okay.
其他人：so
Others: So...
其他人：那你可以来选一个口味
Others: You can choose a flavor now.
Lucia: 那是应该有一包可没用完了
Lucia: There should be a pack, but it's not used up.
其他人：这是一个
Others: This is one.
其他人：两个巧克力
Others: Two chocolates.
其他人：你要巧克力
Others: Do you want chocolate?
其他人：好呀那我们现在拍卖
Others: Okay, now we're auctioning.
其他人：还可以选口味
Others: You can still choose the flavor.
其他人：还可以有选口味的机会
Others: You still have a chance to choose the flavor.
其他人：非常的宝贵
Others: It's very precious.
其他人：因为你后面不拍的话就买不到
Others: Because if you don't bid later, you won't be able to buy it.
其他人：就没有办法选口味
Others: You won't be able to choose the flavor.
其他人：那么我们依旧是一个币起拍
Others: So, we start the bidding at one coin.
其他人：但是我们历史参考价都是两个币
Others: But our historical reference price is two coins.
其他人：史参考价是两个币
Others: Historical reference price is two coins.
其他人：好有没有出价的
Others: Okay, any bids?
其他人：来一个币啊
Others: One coin, come on.
其他人：一个币好
Others: One coin, alright.
其他人：两个币
Others: Two coins.
其他人：还有没有了
Others: Any more bids?
其他人：好那就两个币
Others: Okay, then two coins.
其他人：很明显上面那个在市场上不受欢迎
Others: It's obvious the one above is not popular in the market.
其他人：完了上面这在市场不受欢迎那
Others: Yeah, the one above is not popular in the market.
Alice:录着呢
Alice: We're recording.
其他人：剩下的不好卖
Others: The rest are hard to sell.
Alice:还有这
Alice: And this one.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈自己吃吧
Katrina: Hahaha, just eat it yourself.
小薇其他人：
Tasha: Others:
Katrina: 这什么
Katrina: What is this?
其他人：我们可以可以等待时间检验一下
Others: We can wait for time to test it.
其他人：我们现在先拍这个纸杯蛋糕
Others: Let's shoot this cupcake first.
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
其他人：这是一个新品
Others: This is a new product.
Lucia: 我决定偷走一个谢谢你
Lucia: I've decided to steal one, thank you.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕
Others: This cupcake.
Tasha: 我们刚刚是37点的是吧
Tasha: We were at 37 points, right?
Lucia: 哈哈谢谢你
Lucia: Haha, thank you.
其他人：它的优势在于它附赠一个纸杯
Others: Its advantage is that it comes with a cup.
Tasha: 应该是呃10份1520
Tasha: It should be, uh, 10 portions for 15-20.
其他人：这是一个非常环保的纸杯
Others: This is a very eco-friendly cup.
其他人：而且它这上面的草莓呢
Others: And the strawberry on top...
Lucia: 刚不是我刚咬了一个
Lucia: Didn't I just take a bite of one?
Tasha: 那就15点吧
Tasha: Then let's set it at 15 points.
Tasha: 定个你你定个闹钟
Tasha: Set an alarm.
其他人：个数比较多
Others: There are quite a few.
Lucia: 你可以问问大家吃不吃
Lucia: You can ask if everyone wants to eat.
其他人：至少都是有两半草莓
Others: At least each has two halves of strawberries.
其他人：我们刚刚卖过的这个抹茶蛋挞
Others: The matcha tart we sold earlier...
Lucia: 吃吗买下的同学请大家吃
Lucia: Do you want to eat? Whoever bought it, please share.
其他人：上面只有半片草莓
Others: Only had half a strawberry on top.
其他人：呃同样
Others: Same thing.
Lucia: 先放这吧
Lucia: Let's put it here first.
Lucia: 一会想吃的时候可以吃
Lucia: You can eat it when you feel like it later.
其他人：这个纸杯蛋糕是一个币一个
Others: This cupcake costs one token each.
Lucia: 我蘸一下
Lucia: I'll dip it a bit.
其他人：但是两个币三个
Others: But if you get two, it's three tokens.
其他人：所以我们就可以任意的价格起牌
Others: So we can start the bid at any price.
其他人：是一个币
Others: It's one token.
其他人：买一个还是两个币
Others: Are you buying one or two tokens?
其他人：买3个你可以请吗好
Others: If you buy three, can you please... okay.
其他人：没人出价要留拍了一个币
Others: No one is bidding, so it's one token.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
其他人：那你要要一个吗
Others: Do you want one?
Lucia: 你们
Lucia: You guys...
其他人：啊好你们是一个一个卖的吗
Others: Okay, are you selling them one by one?
其他人：我也可以两个币三个卖
Others: I can also sell three for two tokens.
Shure: 我也可以
Shure: I can also...
Lucia: 可以选好
Lucia: You can choose.
Shure: 两个币3个
Shure: Two tokens for three.
其他人：一个币一个两个币三个
Others: One token for one, two tokens for three.
Lucia: 你俩到底谁在已读乱回哈哈
其他人：你你买不买两个币就是三个
Others: Are you buying or not? Two tokens for three.
其他人：两个币就是三个
Others: Two tokens for three.
其他人：对我没有两个币
Others: I don't have two tokens.
其他人：你没有两个币
Others: You don't have two tokens?
其他人：那你可以向世界银行贷一个
Others: Then you can borrow one from the World Bank.
其他人：哈哈哈不信
Others: Haha, no way.
其他人：你是应该先去银行贷啊
Others: You should go to the bank first.
其他人：不你可以一个币买一个
Others: No, you can buy one for one token.
Lucia: 我去拿包纸
Lucia: I'll go get some napkins.
其他人：你也可以两个币买三个
Others: Or you can buy three for two tokens.
其他人：两个币啊
Others: Two tokens.
Katrina: 其他人：
Katrina: Others:
其他人：你只要给我两个币
Others: Just give me two tokens.
其他人：我就可以把它送给你
Others: And I'll give it to you.
其他人：好坏了下面还有一个完了
Others: Alright, there's one more left.
其他人：哈哈哈两个币买4个我觉得啊
Others: Haha, I think two tokens for four is good.
其他人：那也可以
Others: That works.
其他人：那就那就两个币买4个
Others: Let's do two tokens for four then.
其他人：好我们薄利多销一下
Others: Alright, we'll sell more to make a small profit.
其他人：那我可以把这个把这个盒子送给你
Others: Then I can give you this box.
其他人：入没入账啊
Other: Did it get recorded?
其他人：入没t入账啊
其他人：已经付了姐
Other: It's already paid, sis.
其他人：你帮我给过了
Other: You helped me pay it.
其他人：那书是你的吧
Other: That book is yours, right?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
其他人：是我看过了
Other: I read it already.
Tasha: 你看过了
Tasha: You read it.
Tasha: 你不知道是月亮与六便士是啥
Tasha: Don't you know what "The Moon and Sixpence" is?
其他人：有啥区别啊
Other: What's the difference?
其他人：月亮和月亮与
Other: "The Moon and The Moon and"
其他人：你是银行大股东
Other: You're a major shareholder of the bank.
Tasha: 反正已经反正已经在了
Tasha: Anyway, it's already there.
Shure: 反正已经
Shure: Anyway,
Alice:我
Alice: I
Shure: 反正已经带了
Shure: Anyway, it's already brought.
其他人：：我觉得我们可以走一下
Other: I think we can move on now.
其他人：迅速销售
Other: Rapid sales.
其他人：那改这东西没法卖了
Other: This thing can't be sold anymore.
其他人：这东西卖的不能让他连盆直接端走
Other: This thing can't be sold without taking the whole pot.
其他人：那大家就那个
Other: So let's just
Tasha: 啥呀提拉米苏吗
Tasha: What's that? Tiramisu?
其他人：那我们可以一会再卖
Other: We can sell it later.
其他人：我们可以先中场休息一下
Other: We can take a break now.
Lucia: 这个产品是
Lucia: This product is
其他人：我们甜品的部分在拍卖穿插当中进行
Other: Our dessert part will be auctioned intermittently.
Lucia: 我已经蹲了很长时间了
Lucia: I've been squatting here for a long time.
Lucia: 等待吃它
Lucia: Waiting to eat it.
Katrina: 开始直接room two吧
Katrina: Let's start directly with room two.
Lucia: 我今天怎么回事
Lucia: What's wrong with me today?
Katrina: 然后又吃饭了
Katrina: And then have a meal.
Lucia: 怎么老碰掉各种各样的东西
Lucia: Why do I keep knocking things over?
其他人：这个放在第二个环节
Other: Let's put this in the second session.
其他人：饭还有一会儿才能来
Other: The meal will take a while to come.
Tasha: 嗯还有四五十分钟
Tasha: Yeah, another forty or fifty minutes.
Tasha: 一个小时
Tasha: An hour.
Lucia: 哎你眨了一个那个小眼睛
Lucia: Hey, you winked a little.
其他人：对因为我这个耳钉掉了
Other: Yeah, because my earring fell off.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
其他人：然后不知道在哪我就用这个戴起
Others: Then, I didn't know where it was, so I used this to put it on.
Alice:下一环念啥呀我
Alice: What's the next ring supposed to be?
awww3:turotuor一下子
awww3: turotuor all of a sudden
其他人：你也可以
Others: You can do it too.
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa!
其他人：56789 我收你20%佣金不过分吧
Others: 56789, it's not too much if I charge you a 20% commission, right?
Shure: 参观房间
Shure: Take a tour of the room.
Alice:我我没把那个梗去掉
Alice: I didn't remove that joke.
Tasha: 好不过分
Tasha: That's fine.
Tasha: 哈哈哎
Tasha: Haha, oh well.
Alice:吃吧呀
Alice: Go ahead and eat.
Alice:绿色的没事
Alice: The green one is fine.
Jake:来我truo一下
Jake: Let me try it.
Jake:truo一下之后我们就倒眼镜了
Jake: After trying it, we'll pour the glasses.
Lucia: 让我再去检查一下我的那个有没有掉
Lucia: Let me check if mine has fallen.
其他人：现在精神怎么这么涣散啊
Others: Why is everyone so distracted now?
Lucia: 哦那我不知道啊
Lucia: Oh, I don't know.
Tasha: 有点
Tasha: A little bit.
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow.
Tasha: 真有点哥真有点
Tasha: Really, bro, a little bit.
Shure: 那我的那个闺房十万
Shure: Then my private room is worth a hundred thousand.
Katrina: 放过gas吧
Katrina: Let gas go.
Tasha: 这这消炎药
Tasha: This, this is anti-inflammatory medicine.
Lucia: sorry
Lucia: Sorry.
Tasha: 嗯从一楼开始吧从二楼开始吧
Tasha: Let's start from the first floor, or the second floor.
Katrina: 从一楼开始吗
Katrina: Start from the first floor?
Katrina: 还是什么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure: 从二楼吧从二楼吧来吧
Shure: Let's start from the second floor, come on.
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Let's go.
其他人：吃几个
Others: How many to eat?
Tasha: 吃俩
Tasha: Eat two.
Lucia: 等一下他又掉了
Lucia: Wait, it's fallen again.
Tasha: 这是我的水
Tasha: This is my water.
其他人：这个是你刚刚吃的
Others: This is what you just ate.
Tasha: 这是我的水
Tasha: This is my water.
Tasha: 什么叫哎你
Tasha: What do you mean, hey you?
Tasha: 后面那个就是你的吧
Tasha: The one behind you is yours, right?
Katrina: 刚整理的
Katrina: Just sorted it out.
Katrina: 全全塞这里面了
Katrina: All stuffed in here.
Shure: 这个门票
Shure: This ticket.
Katrina: 哈哈哈就是他给我们
Katrina: Hahaha, he gave us this.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Jake:这是南极
Jake: This is Antarctica.
Katrina: 这是动物派对
Katrina: This is an animal party.
其他人：挂画画
Others: Hanging paintings.
Katrina: 对当然不是我画的
Katrina: Yeah, of course, I didn't draw it.
Jake:看看这看看这个
Jake: Look at this, look at this.
Katrina: 这是我的jellycat
Katrina: This is my Jellycat.
Katrina: 那个是我自己抓的娃娃
Katrina: That's the doll I caught myself.
Katrina: 就那天去
Katrina: That day we went...
Katrina: 我们去嗯去游戏厅
Katrina: We went to the arcade.
Katrina: 我自己抓的娃娃
Katrina: I caught the doll myself.
Katrina: 嗯这是动物party
Katrina: Yeah, this is an animal party.
Tasha: 看不见
Tasha: I can't see.
Katrina: 哈哈哈全部都是动物
Katrina: Hahaha, they're all animals.
Jake:排队参观
Jake: Queue up to visit.
Jake:这个很火
Jake: This is very popular.
Jake:我也来
Jake: I'm joining too.
Tasha: 这是我的
Tasha: This is mine.
Katrina: 还有香薰是吧
Katrina: And there's aromatherapy, right?
其他人：好看好
Others: Looks nice.
Jake:第二轮游客
Jake: Second round of visitors.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina: 当当当当
Katrina: Ta-da!
Katrina: 还做了一块蛋糕
Katrina: And I made a cake.
Katrina: 那我不知道
Katrina: I didn't know that.
Katrina: 我我跟他买的时候没有商量对
Katrina: I didn't discuss it with him when I bought it, right?
其他人：next room
Others: Next room.
Katrina: next room可漂亮了
Katrina: The next room is very pretty.
Jake:很漂亮那大家准备好
Jake: It's beautiful, everyone get ready.
Tasha: 不不不随便开开吧
Tasha: No, no, just open it casually.
Katrina: 多巴胺风格
Katrina: Dopamine style.
Jake:随便开
Jake: Just open it.
Jake:你会和他开是吗
Jake: Are you going to open it with him?
其他人：我已经看过
Others: I've already seen it.
Katrina: 来吧
Katrina: Come on.
其他人：我评价很
Others: My review is very...
Jake:他请进请进
Jake: Please, come in.
Tasha: 你开你开
Tasha: You drive, you drive.
Tasha: 我开不开
Tasha: Should I drive or not?
Jake:我不知道咋开不知道
Jake: I don't know how to drive it.
其他人：目前最好
Others: It's the best so far.
Tasha: 是吗哇
Tasha: Really, wow.
Katrina: 你的真的很漂亮
Katrina: Yours is really beautiful.
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow.
Lucia: 哇好可爱
Lucia: Wow, so cute.
Shure: 哇
Shure: Wow.
Katrina: 绝了好吗
Katrina: It's absolutely amazing, right?
Jake:来介绍一下
Jake: Come on, introduce it.
Lucia: 哇太可爱了吧
Lucia: Wow, it's so cute.
Katrina: 这就是我梦想中的房间
Katrina: This is the room of my dreams.
Katrina: 哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
Katrina: 我拍了给我妈看
Katrina: I'll take a picture to show my mom.
Katrina: 让我妈看
Katrina: Show my mom.
其他人：雇人只需要雇一个艺人就可以了
Others: You just need to hire one artist.
其他人：哈哈哈哈
Others: Hahaha.
Jake:批人是吧
Jake: Critique people, right?
其他人：批人啊对
Others: Critique people, yeah.
其他人：雇人被批人的房房间震撼到了
Others: The room critiqued by the hired person is impressive.
Katrina: 好
Katrina: Okay.
Jake::那我们下一个TRUO还是你要来介绍一下
Jake:不用
Jake: No need.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alrighty.
其他人：好像也不需要介绍对
Others: Seems like it doesn't need an introduction, right?
Lucia: 好像到我这边了是吧
Lucia: Seems like it's my turn, right?
其他人：足够好看并不需要我介绍
Others: It's good enough, it doesn't need me to introduce it.
Jake:艺术品就不需要谢
Jake: Art doesn't need an introduction.
其他人：能把这个小小马还是小狗当一下吗
Others: Can you move this little pony or puppy?
其他人：要不然大家可能不方便过去
Others: Otherwise, it might be inconvenient for everyone to pass by.
Jake:大家有自己的解读
Jake: Everyone has their own interpretation.
Lucia: 希望他希望我墙上粘的这些胶没有掉
Lucia: I hope the glue I used to stick things on the wall hasn't fallen off.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha.
Lucia: 啊没掉
Lucia: Oh, it didn't fall off.
Lucia: 大家快看
Lucia: Everyone, look.
Lucia: 否则他一会就掉了
Lucia: Otherwise, it will fall off soon.
Lucia: 这是一个地中海风格的房间
Lucia: This is a Mediterranean-style room.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Tasha: 挤不进去了
Tasha: There's no room.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 我本来没有那么好奇你
Shure: I wasn't that curious about you before.
Shure: 你这喊完之后我就想看了你知道吗
Shure: But after you yelled, I wanted to see, you know?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Katrina: 怎么了这是
Katrina: What's going on?
Katrina: 一天夸张的好看
Katrina: It's so exaggeratedly beautiful.
Shure: 哦哦可以可以
Shure: Oh, oh, it's okay, it's okay.
Shure: 看着很开心
Shure: Looks happy.
Lucia: 就是它的整体主色调是蓝色和白色
Lucia: The main color scheme is blue and white.
其他人：别搞
Others: Don't mess around.
Lucia: 对就是就是
Lucia: Yes, yes, exactly.
Lucia: 模仿了就是地中海地区
Lucia: It's imitating the Mediterranean region.
Lucia: 就是可能
Lucia: It's probably
Lucia: 主要是希腊那边最常见的建筑风格
Lucia: Mainly the most common architectural style in Greece.
Lucia: 的颜色
Lucia: The colors.
Katrina: 好像参观海洋馆啊
Katrina: Feels like visiting an aquarium.
Lucia: 啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Alice:啊对
Alice: Ah, right.
Tasha: 怎么弹你能教我弹首曲子吗
Tasha: How do you play? Can you teach me a song?
其他人：你要弹什么曲子
Others: What song do you want to play?
Tasha: 不知道
Tasha: I don't know.
Tasha: 你说
Tasha: You tell me.
Tasha: 好我选一个晴天
Tasha: Okay, I'll pick "Sunny Day."
其他人：不会
Others: Can't do it.
Tasha: 他让我选
Tasha: He asked me to choose.
其他人：找谱子
Others: Find the sheet music.
Tasha: 你会什么我弹什么
Tasha: Whatever you can play, I'll play.
其他人：找谱子都会
Others: Find the sheet music, we can all do it.
Tasha: 找谱子好弹等等
Tasha: Find the sheet music, easy to play, hold on.
其他人：不会了
Others: Can't do it.
其他人：啊呜我厉害
Others: Ah woo, I'm awesome.
其他人：这么经典的
Others: Such a classic.
其他人：真不会啊
Others: Really can't do it.
其他人：三级
Others: Grade three.
Jake:好谢谢
Jake: Okay, thanks.
Alice:你的
Alice: Yours.
Jake:还有我的
Jake: And mine.
Alice:呢
Alice: Right.
其他人：他的是塞尔胖克
Others: His is Cyberpunk.
Tasha: 没看见呢
Tasha: I didn't see it.
其他人：赛尔胖克
Others: Cyberpunk.
其他人：不主要这样呢
Others: It's not mainly like this.
其他人：如果你站着的话
Others: If you stand there,
其他人：就会挡住你后面漂亮的小孩
Others: you'll block the pretty kids behind you.
Lucia: 哦没事
Lucia: Oh, it's okay.
Lucia: 因为这个墙不是这床
Lucia: Because this wall isn't this bed.
Shure: 为什么因为那是我的啊
Shure: Why? Because it's mine.
其他人：因为那是我的啊
Others: Because it's mine.
其他人：那是我的
Others: It's mine.
Shure: 你一说巨丑我就想要了
Shure: As soon as you said it's ugly, I wanted it.
其他人：我的
Others: It's mine.
Alice:这个屋这么多电脑
Alice: There are so many computers in this room.
Alice:竟然是住了人的
Alice: And someone actually lives here.
Alice:哈哈哈竟然是住了人的
Alice: Haha, someone actually lives here.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina: 哈哈哈我以为我以为是
Katrina: Hahaha, I thought...
Katrina: 你以为机房是吗
Katrina: You thought it was a computer room, right?
其他人：他可能是住两个人
Others: Maybe two people live here.
Katrina: 哈哈他也在里面住
Katrina: Haha, he also lives in here.
Katrina: 我以为这是个工作间
Katrina: I thought it was a workspace.
Katrina: 他是负责导数据的
Katrina: He's in charge of data importing.
Katrina: 没想到这里一半
Katrina: Didn't expect half of it...
其他人：工作一半是生活嘛
Others: Half work, half living.
Alice:好那可以看我的了
Alice: Okay, now you can look at mine.
Tasha: 怎么回事
Tasha: What's going on?
Alice:我在边边角角
Alice: I'm in the corners.
Tasha: 怎么怎么没看见啊
Tasha: How come I didn't see it?
Tasha: 什么 什么啊
Tasha: What, what?
Alice:别太夸张佳人
Alice: Don't exaggerate, Jaren.
其他人：现在还不能看
Others: You can't see it yet.
Lucia: 哇好好看
Lucia: Wow, it's so pretty.
其他人：哈哈哈闲人免进的情况就是这样
Others: Haha, that's how it is when it's restricted access.
其他人：哈哈哈我姐录
Others: Haha, my sister recorded it.
Lucia: 没掉
Lucia: Didn't fall.
Tasha: 好乱啊
Tasha: It's so messy.
Lucia: 反正我看到的部分都没掉
Lucia: Anyway, the parts I saw didn't fall.
Lucia: 这样特别好好好看
Lucia: It's especially nice, really nice.
其他人：哇
Others: Wow
Tasha: 怎么了
Tasha: What's wrong?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahaha
Lucia: 所以这个耳钉是故意漏出来的吗
Lucia: So, is this earring intentionally showing?
Lucia: 哇塞
Lucia: Wow
其他人：是
Others: Yes
其他人：
Others:
其他人：卧槽牛逼
Others: Damn, that's awesome
Tasha: 卧槽牛逼不
Tasha: Damn, isn't it awesome?
Tasha: 是怎么了
Tasha: What's going on?
其他人：太屌了
Others: That's so cool
Lucia: 好香啊嗯
Lucia: Smells so good, huh
其他人：叹为观止
Others: Breathtaking
其他人：非常的牛逼啊姐
Others: That's really amazing, sis
Katrina: 我的房间非常简约
Katrina: My room is very minimalist
Katrina: 就是理工科
Katrina: It's just like engineering
Katrina: 你看没电脑就摆那
Katrina: See, the computer is just there
其他人：我的个去
Others: Oh my goodness
Katrina: 然后倒头就睡的那种
Katrina: And then you just fall asleep immediately
其他人：哈哈没电了
Others: Haha, no power
其他人：唯一能和你相相提并论的
Others: The only thing that can compare with you
Katrina: 看看
Katrina: Look
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh my
其他人：好好好好好
Others: Good, good, good, good
其他人：哎怎么一股桂花香的味道
Others: Hey, why does it smell like osmanthus?
Tasha: 嗯桂花香薰
Tasha: Yeah, osmanthus incense
Katrina: 嗯桂花香薰
Katrina: Yeah, osmanthus incense
Alice:太心机了
Alice: So cunning
Katrina: 哇
Katrina: Wow
Alice:确实心机
Alice: Really cunning
Katrina: 不是吧
Katrina: No way
Jake:来看看修硕的房间
Jake: Let's take a look at Shure's room
其他人：难道他他房间是不是比较朴素
Others: Isn't his room supposed to be simple?
Lucia: 哎人呢
Lucia: Hey, where is he?
Jake:修硕呢
Jake: Where's Shure?
Jake:修硕在里面是吗
Jake: Is Shure inside?
其他人：起床了哈哈
Others: Wake up, haha
Lucia: 咋回事啊
Lucia: What's going on?
其他人：哈哈哈他说被子还没有叠
Others: Hahaha, he said the bed isn't made yet
Shure: 被子还没有叠
Shure: The bed isn't made yet
其他人：哦
Others: Oh
其他人：他可能不需要叠被子
Others: He might not need to fold the blanket.
Lucia: 他可能不是他
Lucia: He might not be him.
其他人：比较日常
Others: More like a daily routine.
Lucia: 最重要的装修步骤应该就是叠被子
Lucia: The most important renovation step is probably folding the blanket.
Tasha: 然后干嘛呀
Tasha: And then what?
Tasha: 参观完房间
Tasha: After touring the room.
Tasha: 然后干嘛
Tasha: And then what?
Lucia: 金康的参观了吗
Lucia: Did you tour Kingkang's?
Tasha: 然后干嘛
Tasha: And then what?
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
其他人：真的
Others: Really.
其他人：不被允许参观
Others: Not allowed to tour.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 哎人呢
Lucia: Hey, where is he?
Lucia: 哦他也在收拾行吧
Lucia: Oh, he's also tidying up, right.
Tasha: 还要有半个小时才能送到我们这
Tasha: It'll take another half hour to reach us.
Katrina: 哦买噶
Katrina: Oh my god.
Lucia: 哎呦他的房间是最早成型的
Lucia: Wow, his room was the first to take shape.
Tasha: 随便随水就过去了
Tasha: Just go with the flow.
Lucia: 不用收拾
Lucia: No need to tidy up.
Tasha: 半个小时
Tasha: Half an hour.
Tasha: 随便随意
Tasha: Just go with it.
其他人：好好好
Others: Okay, okay, okay.
Lucia: 好好好
Lucia: Okay, okay, okay.
Tasha: 好好你住生活吗
Tasha: Okay, you live a simple life?
其他人：简约是吧
Others: It's minimalist, right?
其他人：那他改造花钱了吗
Others: Did he spend money on the renovation?
Shure: 朴朴素素就是真
Shure: Plain and simple is the truth.
其他人：还不如把这个钱殴下来了
Others: Might as well have saved that money.
Lucia: 好
Lucia: Okay.
其他人：好好
Others: Okay, okay.
Tasha: 殴下了
Tasha: Saved it.
Shure: 这个被子是叠过的啊大家哈哈哈
Shure: This blanket is folded, everyone, hahaha.
Tasha: 这个被子
Tasha: This blanket.
Tasha: 你们不是都花钱买东西
Tasha: Didn't you all spend money on stuff?
Katrina: 哈哈哈看看这被子叠的
Katrina: Hahaha, look at how this blanket is folded.
Tasha: 对啊
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 这被子叠的好呀
Lucia: This blanket is folded well.
Katrina: 好呀叠的好简约啊简约
Katrina: Yeah, folded well, very minimalist, minimalist.
Shure: 叠的好吧
Shure: Folded well, right?
Tasha: 来吧这个大这个大
Tasha: Come on, this one, this one is big.
Lucia: 这个他在里面吗
Lucia: Is he inside?
Tasha: 嗯他说可以开门了他说可以开门了
Tasha: Yeah, he said we can open the door, he said we can open the door.
Lucia: 也在叠被子中
Lucia: Still folding the blanket.
Katrina: 一眼看出理工科
Katrina: You can tell he's an engineering major at a glance.
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈赛博朋克风
Lucia: Hahaha, it's like cyberpunk style.
其他人：赛博朋克风
Others: Cyberpunk style.
Shure: 你怎么又把郁金香放卧室啊
Shure: Why did you put tulips in the bedroom again?
其他人：赛博朋克风
Others: Cyberpunk style.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
其他人：
Others:
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
其他人：这个很好啊
Others: This is really good.
其他人：这居然是个麻将桌
Others: This is actually a mahjong table.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Jake:就是这个
Jake: This is it.
Jake:大家可以想象的到
Jake: You can imagine it.
Jake:我们平时的工作状态
Jake: Our usual work state.
Jake:我们平时一直早要控制8台电脑
Jake: We usually have to control 8 computers.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina: 八爪鱼这地方你还能睡两个人
Katrina: Octopus-like, you can still sleep two people here.
其他人：哈这个地方
Others: Ha, this place.
Lucia: 哈你那个一只手控制8台电脑
Lucia: Ha, you control 8 computers with one hand.
其他人：甚至还能睡两个人
Others: You can even sleep two people.
Lucia: 是有什么梗在里面吗
Lucia: Is there some joke in there?
Tasha: 3个
Tasha: Three of them.
其他人：没有没有睡过三个地方睡两个人
Others: No, no, you sleep two people in three places.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 你确定你不是一只手关掉8台电脑
Lucia: Are you sure you're not shutting down 8 computers with one hand?
其他人：是这么控制啊
Others: That's how you control it, huh?
Katrina: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahahahahahahahaha
其他人：合着是这么个控制吧
Others: So that's how you control it, huh?
Lucia: 你再说一遍哈哈哈
Lucia: Say it again, haha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈对
Tasha: Haha, right.
其他人：有可能在这个位置的时候
Others: Maybe when you're in this position.
其他人：是这么个样子
Others: It's like this.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Tasha: 哈哈就一只手碰掉总电源呗
Tasha: Haha, just one hand to turn off the main power.
其他人：合着总监
Others: So the director
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: 然后他紧急把我叫出来帮他关硬盘
Lucia: And then he urgently called me out to help him turn off the hard drive.
Jake:有一次我不小心碰到这个键
Jake: There was one time I accidentally pressed this key.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahaha
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Jake:我摁了下去
Jake: I pressed it down.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:那那不要
Jake: No, no, don't.
Shure: 插排的那个键
Shure: The switch on the power strip.
Jake:现在把所有的都关掉
Jake: Now turn everything off.
Jake:然后我再拱手离开
Jake: Then I bowed and left.
Lucia: 我觉得这个故事特别精彩
Lucia: I think this story is really exciting.
Katrina: 哈
Katrina: Ha
Lucia: 一定要讲给大家都听听
Lucia: I have to share it with everyone.
Lucia: 今天终于有机会
Lucia: Finally got the chance today.
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 了哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Katrina: 他就一直摁着不敢松吗
Katrina: He just kept pressing and didn't dare to let go?
Lucia: 对他一直摁着
Lucia: Yes, he kept pressing.
Lucia: 摁到所有的硬盘都弹出之后他才敢挂
Lucia: He kept pressing until all the hard drives were ejected, then he dared to hang up.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Katrina: 打仗踩到地雷
Katrina: 不客气
Katrina: No worries.
Lucia: 哈
Lucia: Ha
Alice:你俩也是这个房间的时尚单品
Alice: You two are the fashion items of this room.
Lucia: 笑死我了
Lucia: You're killing me.
Katrina: 蓬头垢面的
Katrina: Looking messy.
Jake:可能大家还没有亲自的放过
Jake: Maybe everyone hasn't personally experienced it yet.
Shure: 那个芍药呢
Shure: Where's the peony?
Jake:大家可以找到自己的电脑
Jake: Everyone can find their own computers.
Jake:然后帮忙
Jake: And help out.
Jake:这个这
Jake: This, this...
其他人：他们已经买下
Others: They've already bought it.
Tasha: 什么东西
Tasha: What is it?
其他人：纸杯蛋糕
Others: Cupcakes.
其他人：我刚想夺走
Others: I was just about to grab one.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Tasha: 这已经买下了
Tasha: This has already been bought.